Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In July of 1991, things looked promising for 18-year-old Julie Dart. A bubbly, spirited teenager with wavy brown hair and a wide smile, she had recently finished high school and was hoping to fulfil her lifelong dream of joining Britain's armed forces. Julie had grown up in Leeds, the largest city in the northern English county of West Yorkshire,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1991年7月，18岁的朱莉·达特（Julie Dart）的前途看起来一片光明。她是一个活泼、有朝气的少女，留着一头棕色波浪卷发，笑起来甜美灿烂。她最近刚高中毕业，希望能实现加入英国武装部队的终身梦想。朱莉在利兹长大，这是英格兰北部西约克郡最大的城市，
where she still lived with her mother. On Tuesday, July 9, 1991, Julie spent the day with her boyfriend, 20-year-old Dominic Murray, who lived in the nearby suburb of Gipton. At six o'clock in the evening, the couple went to Dominic's sister, Rosa's house, where Julie helped prepare a meal of roast lamb and Yorkshire pudding. After they'd eaten, Julie excused herself to start a night shift at the hospital where she'd recently started working as an orderly. At 7.45pm, she kissed Dominic goodbye and departed, wearing a black skirt with a pink and black jacket. At 9pm, Julie phoned Dominic to say she would be working until 11.30pm and would then return to
她一直和母亲住在那里。1991年7月9日，星期二，朱莉和20岁的男友多米尼克·穆雷（Dominic Murray）度过了一天，多米尼克住在附近的吉普顿（Gipton）郊区。傍晚六点，两人来到多米尼克的姐姐罗莎（Rosa）家，朱莉在那里帮忙准备了一顿烤羊肉配约克郡布丁的晚餐。吃完饭后，朱莉告辞去医院上夜班，她最近刚开始在那里做勤杂工。晚上7点45分，她吻别了多米尼克并动身离开，身上穿着一条黑色短裙，外搭一件粉黑相间的夹克。晚上9点，朱莉给多米尼克打电话，说她要工作到晚上11点30分，然后就会回家。
her own home. Dominic noticed that there appeared to be music playing in the background, as though Julie were calling from a pub. Two days passed and Dominic didn't hear from Julie. Then, on the morning of Friday, July 12, he received an unexpected visit from his sister, Rose, who had found a handwritten envelope addressed to him amongst her mail. There was a letter inside, written in Julie's handwriting, which read, Dominic, help me, please. I've been kidnapped and I'm being held as a personal security until next Monday night. Please, go and tell my mum straight away. Love you so much, Dominic. Mum phoned the police straight away and helped me. Have not eaten anything, but I have been off
多米尼克注意到电话背景里似乎有音乐在播放，听起来就像朱莉是从酒吧打来的电话。两天过去了，多米尼克没有收到朱莉的任何消息。接着，在7月12日星期五的早晨，他迎来了姐姐罗斯的意外造访，罗斯在她的邮件中发现了一个写着他名字的手写信封。里面有一封信，是朱莉的笔迹，上面写着：“多米尼克，请救救我。我被绑架了，被当作人质扣押到下周一晚上。求求你，马上去告诉我的妈妈。我非常爱你，多米尼克。妈妈马上报警并帮了我。什么都没吃，但我已经戒掉了
at food. Feeling a bit sick, but I'm drinking two cups of tea per day. Mum, Dominic, help me. Love you all. Julie. After reading the letter, Dominic called Julie's mother, Lynn Dart, who rushed over to read it for herself. She noticed that despite being penned in Julie's handwriting, some of the words and phrasing didn't sound like her daughter at all. Moreover, Lynn couldn't understand why Julie would be abducted and held for ransom as their family had little money. Lynn immediately called the police to report her daughter missing and gave them the letter. Police began looking into Julie's life. Born on March 1, 1973, Julie Ann Dart was the first child of Lynn and Alec Hill, who went on
食物。感觉有点恶心，但我每天喝两杯茶。妈妈，多米尼克，救救我。爱你们所有人。朱莉。”读完这封信后，多米尼克给朱莉的母亲琳恩·达特（Lynn Dart）打了电话，琳恩急忙赶来亲自阅读。她注意到，尽管是朱莉的笔迹，但有些词句和表达方式一点也不像她女儿。此外，琳恩无法理解朱莉为什么会被绑架勒索，因为他们家里并没有多少钱。琳恩立即报警报告女儿失踪，并将这封信交给了警方。警方开始调查朱莉的生活。朱莉·安·达特（Julie Ann Dart）于1973年3月1日出生，是琳恩和亚历克·希尔（Alec Hill）的第一个孩子，两人后来
to have a son named Paul two years later. When Julie was four years old, Alec left his young family, and in 1978, Lynn remarried an electrician named Ian Dart. Both the Julie and Paul were close to their stepfather, calling him dad and adopting his surname. Lynn and Ian separated when Julie was 16 years old, but Ian maintained a relationship with his stepchildren. Although Julie was bright, she wasn't a dedicated student and instead preferred to focus on her athletic abilities. A talented runner, she participated in school and county competitions, accumulating a number of trophies which her mother proudly displayed in the family home. In her spare time, Julie liked socializing, dancing, and performing karaoke with her friends.
在两年后又生了一个儿子，名叫保尔（Paul）。朱莉四岁时，亚历克离开了这个年轻的家庭；1978年，琳恩改嫁给了一名名叫伊恩·达特（Ian Dart）的电工。朱莉和保尔都与继父很亲近，叫他爸爸并随了他的姓。朱莉16岁时，琳恩和伊恩分居了，但伊恩仍与继子女保持着联系。尽管朱莉很聪明，但她并不是一个用功的学生，反而更喜欢把精力放在体育特长上。作为一名有天赋的跑步运动员，她参加了学校和郡级的比赛，赢得了许多奖杯，她的母亲自豪地将这些奖杯陈列在家族的家中。在业余时间，朱莉喜欢社交、跳舞，以及和朋友一起去唱卡拉OK。
While she was still at school, she got a part-time job at a cafe, which was where she met Dominic, a co-worker who was two years her senior. They dated for three years, and when Julie was just 17, they became engaged. Julie moved out of her family home to live with Dominic in his flat, which her mother Lynn didn't approve of. Julie had confided in her younger brother Paul that she and Dominic often argued, and these altercations sometimes became violent. By the end of 1990, the relationship ended, and Julie returned home. She and her mother had always been particularly close, but they both had strong personalities, and living together sometimes resulted in clashes and disagreements.
她还在上学时，就在一家咖啡馆找了一份兼职工作，正是在那里她遇到了比她大两岁的同事多米尼克。他们交往了三年，当朱莉只有17岁时，两人订婚了。朱莉搬出了原生家庭，和多米尼克住进了他的公寓，这并没有得到母亲琳恩的批准。朱莉曾向弟弟保尔吐露，她和多米尼克经常争吵，而且这些争执有时会升级为暴力。到1990年底，这段恋情结束了，朱莉回到了家中。她和母亲一直关系格外亲密，但两人性格都很强势，住在一起有时会导致冲突和分歧。
Julie longed for the day when she could live independently and start a career. Her long-time dream was to become a physical training instructor for the army. She had always been fit and healthy, though she was claustrophobic and suffered from mild asthma as a child. In December of 1990, she visited the Army Recruiting Office in Leeds to apply for a role as a driver in the Women's Royal Army Corps. After several months, her application was accepted, under the condition that she set a final selection examination. On Friday, June 7, 1991, one week before she was due to take the exam, a 41-year-old man named Michael Walter called the Army Recruiting Office.
朱莉渴望着能够独立生活并开始职业生涯的那一天。她长期以来的梦想是成为一名军队的体能训练教官。她一直身体健康、体格健壮，不过她小时候患有幽闭恐惧症和轻度哮喘。1990年12月，她前往利兹的军队招聘办公室，申请加入女子皇家陆军部队（Women's Royal Army Corps）担任司机。几个月后，她的申请被接受了，条件是通过最终选拔考试。1991年6月7日，星期五，也就是她预定参加考试前的一周，一个名叫迈克尔·沃尔特（Michael Walter）的41岁男子给军队招聘办公室打了个电话。
He had befriended Julie several years earlier when she was employed at the cafe, and had eventually offered her a part-time job as a cleaner. Michael was calling to notify the office that Julie had recently stolen two of his bank cards and used them to withdraw £660. She had since signed a liability form, agreeing to repay the money to the bank, but Michael was worried that if she joined the army before settling the debt, the money might never be repaid. The recruitment officer who took the call was concerned, as it was essential that all new recruits were free from financial liability. When questioned by the officer, Julie denied owing any money and proceeded to excel at her
他几年前在咖啡馆工作时与朱莉结识，后来曾提供给她一份清洁工的兼职工作。迈克尔打电话是想通知办公室，朱莉最近偷了他的两张银行卡，并用它们提取了660英镑。她后来签署了一份责任书，同意向银行还款，但迈克尔担心，如果她在清偿债务之前加入军队，这笔钱可能就永远无法追回了。接听电话的招聘官员对此感到担忧，因为所有新兵必须没有债务纠纷，这是至关重要的。面对官员的质询，朱莉否认欠任何钱，并继续在最后的考试中
final exam. She was subsequently accepted for the Army's September intake. Michael Walter repeated his concerns that if Julie didn't settle her debt, the bank would initiate criminal proceedings. Julie continued to deny ever taking the money, but agreed to pay the bank what was owed to enable her to join the armed forces by September. However, on Thursday, July 4, the recruitment officer went to Julie's high school to confirm her final grades and discovered that she had forged her academic records. This resulted in Julie's application being rejected. The recruitment officer sent her a letter explaining the situation that same day, but it is unknown whether Julie ever received it.
表现优异。她随后被录取为军队九月的新兵。迈克尔·沃尔特再次表达了他的担忧，如果朱莉不还清债务，银行将启动刑事诉讼。朱莉继续否认拿过这笔钱，但同意向银行支付所欠款项，以便她能在9月顺利加入武装部队。然而，在7月4日星期四，招聘官员前往朱莉的高中确认她的最终成绩时，却发现她伪造了学业记录。这导致朱莉的申请被拒绝。招聘官员当天就给她寄了一封信解释情况，但目前尚不清楚朱莉是否收到过这封信。
Lynn told the police that there had been nothing happening in Julie's life that had given her any cause for concern. She said that about a month prior, Julie had started experimenting with her physical appearance by trying out different makeup styles and coloring her hair. However, she had dyed it back to its natural color when her grandmother didn't approve. Julie had told her mother that she had recently started a night shift job sterilizing syringes at a laboratory and had been spending nights at the home of an old friend. Police questioned this friend, who revealed she hadn't seen Julie in four months. It soon became clear that Julie and Dominic had reconciled their relationship,
琳恩告诉警方，朱莉的生活中没有任何事情让她感到担忧。她说，大约在一个月前，朱莉开始尝试改变外表，尝试不同的化妆风格和染发。然而，由于祖母不赞成，她又把头发染回了自然颜色。朱莉曾告诉母亲，她最近在一家实验室开始了上夜班的工作，负责给注射器消毒，并且一直在老朋友家里过夜。警方对这位朋友进行了盘问，但对方透露她已经四个月没见过朱莉了。很快，情况变得明朗起来，朱莉和多米尼克已经复合，
but had been keeping it a secret from Julie's family. Dominic often divided his time between the homes of his two sisters, and Julie had occasionally been staying with him while telling her mother she was with her friend. While Lynn believed Julie had a job sterilizing syringes at a laboratory, Dominic was under the impression she worked as an orderly at a hospital. The police inquired with both workplaces, but neither had ever heard of Julie Dart. After filing her report, Lynn walked the streets of Leeds over and over, showing people Julie's photograph. At night, she visited the city's pubs, asking punters whether they had seen her daughter. A number of people recognized
但一直对朱莉的家人保密。多米尼克经常分别住在他的两个姐姐家，而朱莉偶尔会和他住在一起，同时却对母亲说她是和朋友在一起。虽然琳恩相信朱莉在一家实验室做给注射器消毒的工作，但多米尼克则以为她在一家医院做勤杂工。警方询问了这两个工作场所，但都没有听说过朱莉·达特这个人。在报案后，琳恩一遍又一遍地走在利兹的街道上，向人们出示朱莉的照片。到了晚上，她走访市里的酒吧，询问酒客们是否见过她的女儿。许多人认出了
Julie's picture and said they knew her, but none had sighted her within the last week. The police decided to speak with the Vice Squad investigators from the Leeds suburb of Chapeltown, which at the time was a red light district popular with sex workers. From 1975 until 1980, the area was a hunting ground for notorious serial killer, the Yorkshire Ripper, whose crimes were covered in episode 37 of Case File. Although the Vice Squad had no record of Julie, they soon established that multiple witnesses had seen her hanging around the district in the three weeks leading up to her disappearance. She had apparently told some sex workers that she was new to the industry
朱莉的照片并说他们认识她，但没有人在过去的一周内见过她。警方决定与利兹沙佩尔敦（Chapeltouch）郊区的扫黄组（Vice Squad）调查人员交谈，当时该地区是性工作者聚集的红灯区。从1975年到1980年，该地区臭名昭著的连环杀手“约克郡开膛手”（Yorkshire Ripper）的狩猎场，其罪行曾在《案卷》（Case File）第37集中报道过。尽管扫黄组没有朱莉的记录，但他们很快查明，多名目击者看到她在她失踪前的三周内一直在该地区游荡。她显然曾对一些性工作者说她是这个行业的新人，
and had asked their advice on where to take clients and how much to charge. A former classmate of Julie's also came forward, claiming he'd seen her in Chapeltown on Tuesday July 9, the night she went missing. He had been driving through the area at 8.15pm when he spotted Julie standing on a street corner with another girl. They briefly made eye contact, but Julie turned her head away as though she didn't want to be seen. She had been dressed in light blue denim jeans and a white blouse, which was different to the outfit she had been wearing when she left a Dominic half an hour earlier. Inquiries revealed that shortly after this, Julie caught a taxi to a pub with two other young women, and at 9pm she phoned Dominic from the pub's phone.
并向她们征求关于在哪里接客以及收费多少的建议。朱莉的一位前同班同学也站出来，声称他在7月9日星期二（朱莉失踪当晚）在沙佩尔敦见过她。当他于晚上8点15分开车经过该地区时，发现朱莉正和其他女孩站在街角。她们有过短暂的眼神接触，但朱莉把头扭向一边，好像不想被人认出来。她当时穿着浅蓝色牛仔裤和白色衬衫，这与她半小时前离开多米尼克时穿的衣服不同。调查显示，不久之后，朱莉和其他两个年轻女性叫了一辆出租车去了一家酒吧，晚上9点她从酒吧的公用电话给多米尼克打了电话。
She then had a few drinks and played the jukebox before all three women caught a cab to the Chapeltown Street of Spencer Place to engage in sex work. There, Julie spent roughly 20 minutes with a client before buying a takeaway kebab. By 11pm, both of her friends had gone home, leaving Julie standing alone on the corner of Spencer Place and Leopold Street. The discovery that Julie had been engaging in sex work troubled the vice squad. On Friday July 12, the same day that Dominic received the kidnap letter from Julie, the West Yorkshire Police had received an envelope addressed to Leeds City Police, an outdated name that hadn't been used since 1974.
随后她喝了几杯酒，玩了点唱机，然后三个女人一起叫车去了沙佩尔敦的斯宾塞广场（Spencer Place）从事性交易。在那里，朱莉和一名客户呆了大约20分钟，然后买了一个外卖烤肉串（kebab）。到了晚上11点，她的两个朋友都回家了，只留下朱莉独自一人站在斯宾塞广场和利奥波德街（Leopold Street）的街角。发现朱莉曾从事性交易让扫黄组感到不安。7月12日星期五，也就是多米尼克收到朱莉的绑架信的同一天，西约克郡警方收到了一个收件人为“利兹市警察局”（Leeds City Police，这是一个自1974年以来就未再使用的过时名称）的信封。
Inside was a letter typed in red ink, informing officers that a young sex worker had been kidnapped from the Chapeltown area and would be killed, unless the police paid £140,000 in cash. The author also demanded that £5,000 be loaded onto bank cards. Instructions for the handover read. Next Tuesday July 16, a woman police constable will drive to Birmingham New Street station with the money and await a phone call at the phone terminal in the waiting room on platform 9. She must wear a lightish blue skirt with the money in a shoulder bag. She must be there by 6pm and await the call at 7pm. She will then be given the location
里面是一封用红墨水打印的信，信中通知警官，一名年轻的性工作者在沙佩尔敦地区被绑架，如果不支付14万英镑现金，她将被杀害。作案者还要求将5000英镑充值到银行卡中。交接说明上写着：下周二（7月16日），一名女警官将带着现金开车前往伯明翰新街车站（Birmingham New Street station），并在9号站台候车室的电话终端旁等待电话。她必须穿着浅蓝色裙子，钱放在单肩包里。她必须在下午6点前到达，并在7点等待电话。然后她将被告知
of the next phone call. The letter instructed the constable to drive from payphone to payphone, where she would receive further directions along the way. Eventually, at the last sight, a dog leash would be hanging from a tree, ready for her to clip the money to. The cash was to be wrapped in polythene and brown paper, then tied with a nylon cord. The author threatened that if these demands weren't met, a firebomb would go off at a major store in an English city at 5am on Wednesday July 17.
下一个电话的位置。信中指示警官从一个公用电话开车到另一个公用电话，她将在途中接到进一步的指示。最后，在最后一个地点，树上会挂着一条狗绳，供她把钱夹在上面。现金必须用聚乙烯和牛皮纸包裹，然后用尼龙绳捆扎。凶手威胁说，如果不满足这些要求，一枚炸弹将于7月17日星期三上午5点在英格兰某城市的一个主要商店爆炸。
According to the postmarks on the envelope of this letter and the one sent to Dominic, both had been sent at 7pm on Thursday July 11 from the town of Huntingdon, located 135 miles south of Leeds. Realising that they appeared to be dealing with a genuine kidnapping, investigators decided to run an operation in accordance with the kidnappers' instructions. At 6pm on Tuesday July 16, Constable Annette Zeekness went to Birmingham New Street station as instructed, carrying the money in a shoulder bag. Located 120 miles south of Leeds in England's West Midlands region,
根据这封信以及寄给多米尼克的信的信封上的邮戳，两封信都是在7月11日星期七晚上7点从利兹以南135英里处的亨廷顿（Huntingdon）镇寄出的。意识到他们似乎面临着一起真实的绑架案，调查人员决定按照绑架者的指示开展行动。7月16日星期二下午6点，安妮特·齐克尼斯警长（Constable Annette Zeekness）按照指示前往伯明翰新街车站，将现金放在一个单肩包里。该车站位于英格兰西米德兰兹地区利兹以南120英里处，
the station is the busiest and largest of three railway stations that service Birmingham's Central Business District. Undercover officers surveilled Constable Zeekness as she waited for the phone call at the phone terminal in the waiting room at Platform 9. At 6 minutes past 7, the pay phone rang. Constable Zeekness answered it, but the caller on the other end was silent and disconnected the call after several seconds. Constable Zeekness waited another 20 minutes, but no other calls came through. With no further instructions from the kidnapper, investigators were left waiting to see whether the individual would make contact again.
是为伯明翰中央商务区服务的三个火车站中最繁忙、最大的一个。便衣警察在9号站台候车室的电话终端旁监视着齐克尼斯警长等待电话。7点06分，公用电话响了。齐克尼斯警长接了电话，但电话那头的人保持沉默，并在几秒钟后挂断了电话。齐克尼斯警长又等了20分钟，但没有其他电话打进来。由于绑架者没有进一步的指示，调查人员只能等待，看此人是否会再次联系。
Despite the kidnapper's threat to firebomb a city building if their demands weren't met, the following day of Wednesday July 17 passed without incident. Early on the morning of Friday July 19, 51-year-old farmer Bob Skelton was preparing for his day in the rural village of Eastern, 92 miles southeast of Leeds. Bob's farm spanned 579 acres and included a disused railway line. His plan for the day was to relocate his cattle to fresh pastures with the help of his 18-year-old son and another young employee. At 7.45 am, the three men were in a field located alongside the abandoned railway line, half a mile from the A1 motorway, when they noticed a pink and
尽管绑架者威胁如果不满足他们的要求就要炸毁城市建筑，但接下来的7月17日星期三平安无事地过去了。7月19日星期五清晨，51岁的农民鲍勃·斯凯尔顿（Bob Skelton）正准备在利兹东南92英里处的东顿（Eastern）乡村开始一天的工作。鲍勃的农场占地579英亩，其中包括一条废弃的铁路线。他当天的计划是在18岁的儿子和另一名年轻员工的帮助下，将牛群转移到新鲜的牧场。早上7点45分，这三个人在A1高速公路半英里外、紧邻废弃铁路线的一块田地里，注意到草地上躺着一条粉白相间的
white striped sheet lying on the grass. Assuming it was carelessly dumped rubbish, they moved closer and saw that the sheet was bound with lengths of teal-colored rope and something appeared to be wrapped up inside. Bob's son used his penknife to slice the rope and cut a six-inch hole in the sheet, revealing another layer of sheet. Bob thought he could see the outline of a human arm and all three men smelled a strong, unpleasant odor. Bob decided to drive back to the farm to call the police, while the two younger men stood guard over the grisly discovery.
条纹床单。他们以为是被随意丢弃的垃圾，便走近查看，发现床单被几段青色绳索捆绑着，里面似乎包裹着什么东西。鲍勃的儿子用小折刀割断了绳子，在床单上切了一个六英寸的洞，露出了里面另一层床单。鲍勃觉得自己能看到一个人形手臂的轮廓，而且三个人都闻到了一股强烈、难闻的气味。鲍勃决定开车回农场报警，而两个年轻人则留在原地守护这个可怕的发现。
Officers arrived at the scene and unwrapped the sheet. Inside, they found the naked and significantly decomposed body of a young woman. The corpse was taken to be autopsied by Professor Stephen Jones, who noted that the only item the victim was wearing was a gold wishbone ring on her right middle finger. Her head was entirely bald and there were several injuries to her skull, including one at the back of her scalp, another above her left ear and a fracture below the ear. These injuries had likely been caused by a hammer-like weapon, but were not the cause of death. A round the victim's neck was a ligature mark, indicating she had also been strangled.
警察赶到现场并打开了床单。在里面，他们发现了这名年轻女性赤裸且严重腐烂的尸体。尸体被送去做尸检，由斯蒂芬·琼斯教授（Professor Stephen Jones）负责，他注意到死者身上唯一的物品是右手无名指上戴着一枚黄金许愿骨戒指。她的头部完全秃了，头骨有多处损伤，包括后脑勺的一处、左耳上方的一处以及耳下一处骨折。这些伤很可能是由锤状武器造成的，但并不是死因。死者颈部有一道勒痕，表明她还曾被勒死。
Her right ankle featured chain-like bruises, suggesting she had been made to wear some sort of leg restraint. Due to the state of decomposition, Professor Jones was unable to determine whether she had been sexually assaulted. It was determined that the victim had likely been killed a week prior to being discovered, but the grass beneath where the body had been found showed no discoloration, indicating it had only been dumped hours earlier. Using clear adhesive tape, forensic scientists recovered a number of fibers from the sheet, including yellow wool and brown nylon fibers, which appeared to have originated from a mustard
她的右脚踝有链条状的瘀伤，表明她曾被迫佩戴某种腿部约束装置。由于腐烂程度严重，琼斯教授无法确定她是否遭到性侵。经确定，死者很可能在被发现前一周就被杀害了，但发现尸体下方的草地没有变色，这表明尸体是几小时前才被抛弃的。法医科学家使用透明胶带从床单上收集了许多纤维，包括黄色羊毛和棕色尼龙纤维，这些纤维似乎源自一条芥末色的地毯。
colored carpet. These same yellow and brown fibers were also found in the rope that had been used to tie the sheet. An electronic message was sent out to police forces around the country to inform them that an unidentified body had been found. The message caught the attention of Detective Chief Superintendent Bob Taylor of the West Yorkshire Police, who had been investigating Julie Dart's disappearance. Julie had a chipped tooth, leading Superintendent Taylor to inquire whether the unidentified victim shared this characteristic. When it was confirmed that she did, Julie's dental records were summoned, and on Saturday, July 20, the victim was positively identified as 18-year-old Julie Dart. That night, Superintendent Taylor went to Lynn Dart's home
这些黄色和棕色纤维也在用于捆绑床单的绳索中被发现。一份电子消息被发送到全国各地的警察部队，通知他们发现了一具无名女尸。这条消息引起了西约克郡警察局总督察鲍勃·泰勒（Bob Taylor）的注意，他一直在调查朱莉·达特的失踪案。朱莉有一颗崩掉的牙齿，这促使泰勒总督察询问这具无名受害者是否也有这个特征。当被证实确实有时，朱莉的牙科记录被调出，7月20日星期六，死者被正式确认正是18岁的朱莉·达特。那天晚上，泰勒总督察来到琳恩·达特的家中
to inform her of the news, bringing with him the gold wishbone ring recovered from Julie's body. The devastated mother identified the ring as a gift she had given Julie for her 18th birthday, four months prior. Witnesses who had seen anything suspicious in the area near Bob's Gelton's farm were encouraged to come forward. Several individuals reported that two hours before Julie's body was found, they had been travelling on a bus along High Dyke Road in Easton, when they noticed a red car up ahead and to the right. The vehicle was approaching the road from a track next to the pasture where Julie's body was found, and it was being driven by a white, lone male. Police had initially considered whether Julie's boyfriend, Dominic Murray,
向她通报这一消息，并带来了从朱莉尸体上取下的黄金许愿骨戒指。悲痛欲绝的母亲认出这枚戒指是她四个月前送给朱莉18岁生日的礼物。警方鼓励任何在鲍勃·盖尔顿（Bob Gelton，注：此处播客原文有误，指前文鲍勃·斯凯尔顿）农场附近地区看到可疑情况的目击者站出来提供线索。几个人报告说，在朱莉的尸体被发现前两小时，他们正坐着公交车沿东顿的高戴克路（High Dyke Road）行驶，这时他们注意到前方右侧有一辆红色的汽车。这辆车正从紧邻发现朱莉尸体牧场的一条小路驶向公路，车由一名独行的白人男子驾驶。警方最初曾考虑朱莉的男友多米尼克·穆雷
could be responsible for her murder. However, he didn't own a car, and two days before Julie's disappearance, he had sustained an injury that would have made it impossible for him to dispose of her body alone. At 2am on Sunday July 7, he and Julie had been walking home together after a night drinking at the pub. An off-duty constable noticed that Julie could hardly stand and that her face was swollen and her lip was bloody. Dominic was propping her up and slapping her, so the constable intervened and Dominic fell, breaking his ankle. He and Julie were taken to the hospital and kept there overnight, with Dominic having a cast put on his left foot. Julie's older friend Michael Walter, who had alerted the Army recruitment office to her theft
是否应该对她的谋杀负责。然而，他没有汽车，而且在朱莉失踪前两天，他受过伤，这使得他不可能独自处理她的尸体。7月7日星期日凌晨2点，他和朱莉在酒吧喝酒后一起步行回家。一名休班警员注意到朱莉几乎站不稳，而且她的脸肿了，嘴唇流血。多米尼克正在支撑着她并扇她耳光，因此这名警员介入了，多米尼克摔倒并摔断了脚踝。他和朱莉被送到医院并在那里过夜，多米尼克的左脚打上了石膏。朱莉的年长朋友迈克尔·沃尔特（Michael Walter）曾向军队招聘办公室举报她盗窃
of his bank cards, was also considered a suspect. Believing he had a motive, police arrested him for questioning a week after Julie's disappearance. He was released on Thursday July 18, but police ordered that he be kept under constant surveillance. As he was still being monitored when Julie's body was discovered the next day, he was ruled out as a suspect. Three days after Julie's body was found, the police received another letter claiming to be from the kidnapper. This typed message had been sent from Leeds Railway Station and was postmarked Sunday July 22 at Red. Words will never be able to express my regret that Julie Dart had to be killed, but I did warn what would happen if anything went wrong.
他的银行卡，也被列为嫌疑人。认为他有作案动机，警方在朱莉失踪一周后将他逮捕并进行审讯。他在7月18日星期日被释放，但警方下令对他实施严密监视。由于第二天发现朱莉尸体时他仍在受监控，因此他被排除在嫌疑人之外。在发现朱莉尸体三天后，警方收到了另一封自称来自绑架者的信。这封打印的信件是从利兹火车站寄出的，邮戳日期为7月22日星期日。信上写道：“言语永远无法表达我对朱莉·达特不得不被杀害的遗憾，但我确实警告过如果出事会发生什么。
At the time of this letter, there has been no publicity. If you do not find the body within a few days, I will contact you as to the location. She was not raped or sexually abused or harmed in any way until she met her aunt. She was tied up and hit a few blows to the back of the head to render her unconscious and then strangled. She never saw what was to happen. Never felt no pain or knew anything about it. The fire bomb was not left as promised as the sealant around the combustibles must have got knocked in transit and smelled badly, so it was never placed. Owen's furniture store in Coventry was to be the target. I still require the same monies as before under the same conditions.
在这个信件发出时，还没有任何公开报道。如果你在几天内找不到尸体，我会联系你告知地点。在她遇到她阿姨之前，她没有被强奸、性虐待或受到任何伤害。她被绑起来，头部后方挨了几下打以致昏迷，然后被勒死。她从未看到将要发生的事情。从未感到痛苦或对此一无所知。正如承诺的那样，炸弹没有留下，因为易燃物周围的密封件在运输过程中一定被撞坏了，气味很难闻，所以根本没有放置。考文垂的欧文家具店（Owen's furniture store）本来是目标。我仍然需要和以前一样金额的钱，条件也一样。
If you want to avoid serious fire damage and any further prostitutes lives, place an ad in the personal column of The Sun to read. Let's try again for Julie's sake. Convinced the letter was genuinely penned by Julie's killer, on Saturday July 27, the police placed an ad in the Sun newspaper as instructed. On Tuesday July 30, they received a handwritten letter from the kidnapper acknowledging the ad and warning that another hostage would soon be taken. He instructed Constable Annette Zeekness to travel to a particular payphone alongside the M1 motorway in the county of Leicester that evening and await his call. Constable Zeekness waited by the payphone as directed.
如果你想避免严重的火灾损失以及更多妓女的生命，请在《太阳报》的个人专栏中刊登一幅广告，内容如下：为了朱莉的缘故，让我们再试一次。”坚信这封信确实是由朱莉的杀手亲笔写的，7月27日星期六，警方按照指示在《太阳报》上登了广告。7月30日星期二，他们收到了一封绑架者的手写信，确认了这则广告，并警告说很快会劫持另一个人质。他指示安妮特·齐克尼斯警长当晚前往莱斯特郡M1高速公路旁的一个特定公用电话亭并等待他的电话。齐克尼斯警长按照指示在公用电话旁等候。
When the call came, instead of speaking directly into the phone, the kidnapper played an audio recording. Constable Zeekness explained that she was unable to hear the message over the noise of the traffic, but the line went dead. Two days later, on Thursday August 1, the kidnapper sent another letter ordering Constable Zeekness to return to the same payphone in Leicester on Tuesday August 6. She followed these instructions, but no call came through. Three days after that, police received a letter from the kidnapper explaining that he'd been unable to find a suitable hostage in time. He told Constable Zeekness to return to the phone booth on Wednesday August 14 at 8.15pm, threatening, quote,
当电话打来时，绑架者没有直接对着电话说话，而是播放了一段录音。齐克尼斯警长解释说，由于交通噪音太大，她听不清留言，但电话线就此中断了两天后，即8月1日星期四，绑架者又寄来一封信，命令齐克尼斯警长在8月6日星期二返回莱斯特的同一个公用电话亭。她遵循了这些指示，但没有电话打进来。三天后，警方收到绑架者的信，解释说他未能及时找到合适的人质。他告诉齐克尼斯警长于8月14日星期三晚上8点15分返回电话亭，并威胁说，原话是：
This will be the last time you will receive a call at the usual location. Should anything go wrong, you will not then be given the location of the incendiary device or the prostitute's body. On August 14, the call came through as promised, and the kidnapper spoke to Constable Zeekness directly, claiming to have abducted a sex worker named Sarah Davies from the town of Ipswich. He provided directions to another phone box near the M1 motorway and told Constable Zeekness to be there by 9.45pm. She arrived in time, but when she answered the call, the kidnapper said he'd encountered some problems and would call back in half an hour. The phone rang again 30 minutes later,
“这将是你最后一次在通常的地点接到电话。如果出现任何差错，你将不会被告知燃烧装置或妓女尸体的地点。”8月14日，电话如约打来，绑架者直接与齐克尼斯警长通话，声称从伊普斯威奇（Ipswich）镇绑架了一名名叫莎拉·戴维斯（Sarah Davies）的性工作者。他提供了通往M1高速公路附近另一个电话亭的路线，并告诉齐克尼斯警长必须在晚上9点45分之前到达那里。她按时到达，但当她接听电话时，绑架者说他遇到了一些问题，将在半小时后回电。30分钟后电话再次响起，
but the phone's cradle had jammed and Constable Zeekness struggled to answer it. By the time she was able to pick up the receiver, the caller had hung up. Constable Zeekness waited for another half hour, but the phone didn't ring again. The West Yorkshire police checked whether anyone named Sarah Davies had gone missing from Ipswich, but no reports of this nature had been made. They concluded that the caller had lied about the kidnapping in order to increase pressure on police. The following day, some men were walking underneath the disused railway bridge on the M1 motorway near the phone box that had jammed when they found what appeared to be a small bomb. The device was shaped like a tin can
但电话机叉簧卡住了，齐克尼斯警长费力地接听。等她拿起话筒时，对方已经挂断了。齐克尼斯警长又等了半小时，但电话没有再响。西约克郡警方核实了伊普斯威奇是否有名叫莎拉·戴维斯的人失踪，但没有收到此类报告。他们得出结论，打电话的人为了加大对警察的压力，谎称了绑架。第二天，一些人在M1高速公路靠近卡住的电话亭的那座废弃铁路桥下行走时，发现了一个看似小型炸弹的物体。该装置呈罐头形状，
and attached to one end was a wire and a small red plastic cube. Responding officers from the South Yorkshire police were unaware that their colleagues in West Yorkshire had been interacting with a possible extortionist and suspected the device was a fake. This was confirmed by a bomb disposal officer who arrived on the scene to investigate. Nearby, police found a brick that had been painted white and had an envelope attached that was marked with the number three. Inside, a hand stenciled note read, message next bridge 400 meters, detector on panel, carry money. When the news spread to the West Yorkshire police, they were certain the items had been left by
一端连接着一根电线和一个红色的塑料小方块。南约克郡警方的出警人员并不知道他们西约克郡的同事一直在与可能的勒索者互动，并怀疑该装置是假的。这一点得到了赶到现场调查的拆弹专家的证实。在附近，警方发现了一块被漆成白色的砖头，上面贴着一个标有数字3的信封。里面有一张手写 stencil（注：镂花模板/手写字条）的纸条，上面写着：“下一座桥400米处有信息，面板上有探测器，带着钱。”当这个消息传到西约克郡警方时，他们确信这些物品是他们的
their suspect and that the disused bridge was his intended location for the money drop. To test their theory, they carried out a reconstruction at the site. Had Constable Zeekness been able to receive the second phone call, the police deduced that she would have been directed to the bridge and to the fake incendiary device. From there, she would have placed the device, which the suspect had referred to as a detector, on her car dashboard and driven to the next bridge 400 meters away. There, as per the kidnapper's original letter, he would have intended to stand on the bridge and lower a dog leash for Constable Zeekness to clip the bundle of money too.
嫌疑人留下的，并且那座废弃的桥是他预定的送钱地点。为了检验他们的理论，他们在现场进行了重演。警方推断，如果齐克尼斯警长能够接到第二个电话，她就会被指引导向那座桥和那个假燃烧装置。从那里，她会将嫌疑人称之为探测器的装置放在汽车仪表盘上，然后开车去400米外的下一座桥。在那里，按照绑架者最初的信件，他打算站在桥上垂下一条狗绳，供齐克尼斯警长把那捆钱夹在上面。
The kidnapper would have then intended to haul up the money and attempt an escape. Ten days later, a discovery in the South Yorkshire town of Barnsley revealed that the kidnapper had planned yet another step which police had missed. An envelope labeled with the number two was found taped underneath a shelf in one of the town's phone booths. Inside was a note providing directions to the fake incendiary device and white brick. Investigators determined that the kidnapper had actually planned to direct Constable Zeekness to this pay phone first to receive the instructions, but his plan had been thwarted when the phone receiver jammed at the previous phone booth.
然后，绑架者会把钱拉上去并试图逃跑。十天后，南约克郡巴恩斯利（Barnsley）镇的一个发现表明，绑架者还计划了警方漏掉的另一个步骤。在镇上的一个电话亭内，人们发现了一个贴在货架底下的标有数字2的信封。里面是一张纸条，提供了通往假燃烧装置和白砖的路线。调查人员确定，绑架者实际上计划先将齐克尼斯警长指引到这个公用电话来接收指示，但由于前一个电话亭的话筒卡住，他的计划落空了。
On Monday, August 19, police received a letter from the kidnapper that read, Games now abandoned. Crime Watch UK will tell me most of what I wanted to know. You'll have to file your papers until I try again. As you know, I never picked anyone up in Ipswich or planted a device. I didn't need to. Following Julie's unfortunate death, you'd cooperate with anything I wanted. For your records, Julie was picked up on Tuesday, July 9, 11.30pm. The reason the body deteriorated so quick was that it was kept in a wheelie bin in a greenhouse for two very hot days. Her head was wrapped in a towel, but when this was removed to clean her up
8月19日星期星期一，警方收到一封来自绑架者的信，上面写着：“游戏现在放弃了。英国犯罪观察（Crime Watch UK）会告诉我大部分我想知道的事情。在你再次尝试之前，你得把文件存档。如你所知，我从未在伊普斯威奇接走任何人，也没有放置任何装置。我不需要。在朱莉不幸身亡后，你会配合我想要的任何事情。为了你的记录，朱莉是在7月9日星期二晚上11点30分被接走的。尸体之所以恶化得这么快，是因为它被放在温室里的一个带轮垃圾桶里整整两天，当时天气非常炎热。她的头部包着一条毛巾，但当为了清理她而将其取下时
before dropping her, her hair came away, stuck to the blood on the towel. As none of these details about Julie's body had been released to the media, the police forwarded the letter to a pathologist to verify the kidnapper's claims. Professor Stephen Jones confirmed that the state Julie's body was in was consistent with having been stored in a plastic bin inside a greenhouse, as the killer described. In order to gain further insight as to the type of individual they were dealing with, police retained criminal psychologist Paul Britton to create a profile of the suspect. Britton concluded that the suspect was likely aged in his late 40s or early 50s and was a
在抛尸之前，她的头发脱落了，粘在了毛巾上的血迹上。”由于这些关于朱莉尸体的细节从未向媒体公开，警方将这封信转发给了一位病理学家，以核实绑架者的说法。斯蒂芬·琼斯教授证实，朱莉尸体的状态与正如凶手所描述的那样，曾被存放在温室里的塑料桶中相符。为了进一步了解他们所面对的个体的类型，警方聘请了犯罪心理学家保罗·布里顿（Paul Britton）来对嫌疑人进行心理画像。布里顿得出结论，嫌疑人可能年龄在40多岁末或50多岁初，是一个
careful planner. As his letters were riddled with grammatical and spelling errors, he likely had a secondary level education but no university degree. In terms of occupation, he likely worked in a field that required a high level of technical knowledge but not a high level of technical skills. He wanted to be taken seriously by police and have them engage him as a high level adversary. Although murder wasn't the primary aim of the crime and the suspect probably hadn't killed before, Britton concluded that he would kill again, unless he was caught. As the suspect's letters had been posted from various locations, it was clear that whoever had sent them had the time and freedom to travel.
仔细的规划者。由于他的信件中充斥着语法和拼写错误，他可能接受过中等教育，但没有大学学位。在职业方面，他可能从事需要高水平技术知识但不需要高水平技术技能的领域。他希望被警方认真对待，并让他们将他视为高水平的对手。尽管谋杀不是犯罪的主要目的，而且嫌疑人以前可能没有杀过人，但布里顿得出结论，除非被捕，否则他会再次杀人。由于嫌疑人的信件是从不同地点寄出的，很明显，无论谁寄出这些信件，都有时间和自由去旅行。
They were sent to a forensic document examiner in Birmingham who determined that the typed letters were written using an Olivetti manual type bar typewriter that had damage to its typefaces. Several keys were missing particular elements, including the lower left portion of the number zero and part of the lower case F. Consequently, it was estimated that the machine was between 20 to 30 years old. The handwritten letters were mostly penned using messy capital letters, possibly by the kidnapper using his non-dominant hand. Despite his obvious attempts to disguise his handwriting, consistent features were noted in how he drew particular letters of the alphabet. Furthermore, given that he referred to the West Yorkshire Police by their old name of Leeds City
它们被送往伯明翰的一名法庭文件检验员那里，该检验员确定这些打印信件是使用一台字模受损的Olivetti手动打字机书写的。几个键缺少特定元素，包括数字0的左下部分和小写字母f的一部分。因此，据估计这台机器已有20到30年的历史。手写信件大多是用凌乱的大写字母书写的，可能是绑架者用非习惯手写的。尽管他明显企图掩饰自己的笔迹，但在他如何书写字母表中特定字母时，仍能注意到一致的特征。此外，鉴于他用旧称“利兹市警察局”来指代西约克郡警察局，
Police, it was suggested that the kidnapper could be an older individual with a grudge against the force. An examination of the fake bomb revealed it had been crafted from a container of fish food that had been painted silver. The white painted brick was harder to identify. It wasn't of a standard brick size and was originally blue instead of a typical red colour. Chemical and mineral analysis revealed that the brick had been made from a particular clay found at a quarry in the county of Staffordshire. Only one company in the country manufactured this sort of brick, which was used to construct road gutters. On Wednesday, August 21, the police held a press conference to share some of the details
有人认为绑架者可能是一个对该部队心怀怨恨的老年人。对假炸弹的检查显示，它是用一个被漆成银色的鱼食容器制作的。刷成白色的砖块更难识别。它不是标准砖块尺寸，而且原本是蓝色的，而不是典型的红色。化学和矿物分析显示，这块砖是用斯塔福德郡（Staffordshire）一个采石场发现的一种特定黏土制成的。全国只有一家公司制造这种砖，用于建造道路排水沟。8月21日星期三，警方举行了新闻发布会，分享了一些他们一直刻意隐瞒的关于
about Julie's murder that they had intentionally been withholding. They revealed that one of the kidnapper's letters contained indentations from another message that had been written on a sheet of paper placed on top. It read, Mavis will not be in on Tuesday. Fill. On Thursday, September 12, Julie's case was covered by Crime Watch, a monthly BBC program that shared information about unsolved crimes and requested viewers' assistance in solving them. Reconstructions depicting Julie's last known movements were aired, along with the red car that was spotted by the field where her body was found. The coverage prompted 400 viewers to phone in with information, including one man who claimed to have had a sexual encounter with Julie
朱莉谋杀案的细节。他们透露，绑架者的一封信中包含了一些压痕，这些压痕来自放在上方的一张纸上写着的另一条信息。上面写着：“玛维斯（Mavis）周二不来。填空。”9月12日星期星期四，朱莉的案件被BBC的月度节目《犯罪观察》（Crime Watch）报道，该节目分享有关未破悬案的信息，并请求观众协助破案。节目播出了重现朱莉最后已知行踪的画面，以及在发现她尸体的田野旁被发现的那辆红色汽车。这篇报道促使400名观众打电话提供信息，其中包括一名声称与朱莉有过性接触的男子
one week before her disappearance. He said the two had met in a Leeds pub and he later gave Julie a lift in his car. They chatted for an hour, during which Julie revealed she had taken up sex work to repay a debt so that she could join the army. Another man called asking to speak to Superintendent Bob Taylor directly before abruptly hanging up the phone. This led police to consider whether the caller had been the kidnapper himself. On October 16, 1991, after two months of silence, the police received another handwritten letter from the kidnapper. It read, As you are nowhere near on my tail, the time has come to collect my 140,000 pounds from you. I do not get any bigger sentence for two murders and prostitutes are easy
在她失踪前一周。他说两人在利兹的一家酒吧相遇，他后来开车载了朱莉一程。他们聊了一个小时，期间朱莉透露她开始从事性工作是为了还清债务以便参军。另一名男子打电话要求直接与鲍勃·泰勒总督察通话，随后突然挂断了电话。这导致警方考虑打电话的人是否就是绑架者本人。1991年10月16日，在两个月的沉默之后，警方收到了绑架者的另一封手写信。信中写道：“既然你们根本没追踪到我，现在是时候从你们那儿拿走我的14万英镑了。两起谋杀判的刑不会更重，而且妓女很容易
to pick up. He ordered Constable Zeekness to go to a payphone at the Carlisle train station in Northwest England at 8pm on Wednesday, October 21 and wait for his call. Investigators were confused as October 21 was actually a Monday, not a Wednesday. Moreover, the phone box the kidnapper described had been relocated years earlier. Nevertheless, they sent their crime squad to the location on both Monday and Wednesday, but received no further contact from their suspect. On October 15, a menacing letter had also been sent to the London headquarters of British Rail, the state-owned company that operated most of Great Britain's overground rail transport. It had been sent five days prior from the city of Stoke-on-Trent in Staffordshire.
拐走。”他命令齐克尼斯警长于10月21日星期三晚上8点前往英格兰西北部的卡莱尔（Carlisle）火车站的公用电话亭等待他的电话。调查人员感到困惑，因为10月21日实际上是星期一，而不是星期三。此外，绑架者描述的电话亭几年前就已经被搬迁了。尽管如此，他们还是在周一和周三派出了犯罪小队前往该地点，但没有收到嫌疑人的进一步联系。10月15日，一封带有威胁意味的信件也被寄往了英国铁路公司（British Rail）位于伦敦的总部，这家国营公司运营着大不列颠大部分的地上铁路运输。这封信是五天前从斯塔福德郡的特伦特河畔斯托克（Stoke-on-Trent）市寄出的。
Over two typed pages, the author threatened to derail a high-speed train and less 200,000 pounds in cash was delivered by two female employees on Wednesday, October 23. The employees were directed to go to a payphone at crew station in Cheshire to receive further instructions, with a stenciled message warning, your females will be in danger if money not real. Throughout the letter, the pronoun we was used repeatedly, giving the impression that more than one person was behind the extortion scheme. Detective Chief Superintendent Pat Fleming from the London Metropolitan Police was assigned to coordinate the railway thread inquiry and began looking into possible links with other blackmail schemes, including the Julie Dark case.
作者在两页打字纸上威胁要炸毁一辆高铁，并要求在10月23日星期三由两名女员工交付20万英镑现金。这两名员工被指示前往柴郡克鲁车站的公用电话亭接受进一步指示，并附有一条用模板印制的警告信息：如果钱不是真的，你们的女性将处于危险之中。信中自始至终多次使用代让人觉得这起勒索计划的背后不止一人。伦敦警察厅的侦探总督察帕特·弗莱明被指派协调铁路威胁调查，并开始调查与包括朱莉·达特案在内的其他勒索计划可能存在的联系。
On Monday, October 21, senior officers from both investigations compared their respective letters and discovered there were a number of similarities. Both included stenciled writing, the use of technical language and diagrams, and instructed women to act as couriers to deliver money in a similar fashion. As the British rail extortionist was requesting that money be delivered on the same day that officers from the Julie Dart inquiry would be carrying out their own operation, police suspected the perpetrator was attempting to tie up their resources. At 7pm on Wednesday, October 23, a female police officer went to crew station to await the extortionist's phone call. Eight minutes later, a call came through, during which the caller
10月21日星期一，这两起调查的高级警官比对各自的信件后发现有许多相似之处。两封信都包含模板印刷的文字、技术语言和图表，并指示女性作为信使以类似的方式运送钱款。由于英国铁路勒索犯要求在朱莉·达特案的警察开展自身行动的同一天交付钱款，警方怀疑作案者企图牵制他们的警力。10月23日星期三晚上7点，一名女警官前往克鲁车站等待勒索者的电话。八分钟后，一个电话打进来，期间打电话的人
repeatedly asked hello, before hanging up. The phone rang again shortly afterwards, but stopped before it could be answered, and the operation was subsequently aborted. On Monday, October 28, another letter arrived at British Rail, stating, congratulations, you have now qualified for retribution. The extortionist threatened to take down a section of a train line and remove an electric local pantograph, which is an apparatus that connects a train to a line overhead. A week later, on Monday, November 4, British Rail track chargeman Dennis Parton was conducting a routine inspection of the West Coast line, which runs from London to Glasgow. He was focusing on
反复问“喂”，然后挂断了。不久后电话又响了，但在接听前停了下来，随后行动被取消。10月28日星期一，另一封信送达英国铁路公司，上面写着：“恭喜，你们现在有资格获得报应了。”勒索者威胁要摧毁一段铁路线并拆除电力机车受电弓，这是一种将列车连接到架空线的装置。一周后的11月4日星期一，英国铁路轨道工头丹尼斯·帕顿正在对西海岸干线进行例行巡检，该线路从伦敦延伸至格拉斯哥。他重点检查了
an eight mile stretch that ran south between crew station and Stafford station, when he came to a bridge near the Staffordshire village of Millmeese. Under the bridge, Dennis noticed that a broken concrete block, some sandstone, and a piece of rope were lying between the rails. He notified the British Transport Police, who determined that the extortionist had likely tied the concrete to one end of the rope and the sandstone to the other. Using the concrete end as an anchor, he then threw the sandstone end over the train line, with the intention of damaging a passing train's pantograph. If this plan had succeeded, the train would have lost power and potentially caused significant damage to both the train and those on board.
位于克鲁车站和斯塔福德车站之间向南延伸八英里的路段，当时他来到了斯塔福德郡米尔米斯村附近的一座桥下。在桥下，丹尼斯注意到两根铁轨之间躺着一块破碎的混凝土块、一些砂岩和一段绳子。他通知了英国交通警察局，警方确定勒索者很可能将混凝土系在绳子的一端，砂岩系在另一端。他以混凝土端作为锚，将砂岩端扔过铁路线，企图损坏过往列车的受电弓。如果这个计划成功，列车将会断电，并可能对列车及车上人员造成重大损害。
On Thursday, November 7, the Julie Dart Inquiry was formally linked with the British Rail case, and West Yorkshire Police were awarded responsibility for both investigations. That same day, Julie's funeral was held in Leeds. Almost four months had passed since her body was discovered, and 300 mourners gathered to pay their respects, including a number of police officers who had been working tirelessly on solving her case. Julie's family were devastated by the revelation that she had been struggling with finances, an abusive relationship, and her army application, and had chosen to keep these troubles to herself. Her maternal grandparents, Margaret and Harvey Aitken, had always told their grandchildren
11月7日星期四，朱莉·达特案正式与英国铁路案并案调查，西约克郡警察局被授予对这两起调查的管辖权。同一天，朱莉的葬礼在利兹举行。自她的尸体被发现以来已经过去了近四个月，300名哀悼者聚集在一起表示哀悼，其中包括许多为侦破她的案件而不懈努力的警官。朱莉的家人得知她一直在为财务问题、虐待关系和参军申请苦恼，却选择将这些烦恼深埋心底，对此感到悲痛欲绝。她的外祖父母玛格丽特和哈维·艾特金一直告诉他们的孙辈
to come to them any time they needed help. Margaret later stated, I think of Julie every day. It still breaks my heart that she couldn't come to us and tell us what was wrong. Police continued to work the case, but no substantial leads emerged. On January 16, 1992, an inquest into Julie's death was held, with the coroner ruling her death had been an unlawful killing by person or persons unknown. Six days later, on the morning of Wednesday, January 22, 1992, real estate agent Stephanie Slater was preparing for work. The 25-year-old lived with her parents in Birmingham and had recently started a new job at Shipways Estate Agents, an offshoot of one of England's largest
无论何时需要帮助都要找他们。玛格丽特后来表示：“我每天都想起朱莉。每当想到她不能来找我们倾诉到底出了什么问题，我的心就依然碎裂。”警方继续调查此案，但没有出现实质性线索。1992年1月16日，关于朱莉死因的研讯举行，验尸官裁定她的死是由未知一人或多人实施的非法杀害。六天后，即1992年1月22日星期三早晨，房地产经纪人斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特正准备去上班。这位25岁的姑娘与父母住在伯明翰，最近刚在“船坞房地产公司”找到了一份新工作，这是英国最大保险集团之一的分支机构。
insurance groups. Things were going well for Stephanie. She liked her new job, she had a boyfriend and an active social life, and had just booked a two-week summer holiday with a friend. The pair were planning to visit the Isle of Wight, a picturesque island south of England, that Stephanie had often visited as a child. By the time Stephanie was ready for work, her parents had already left for the day. She gave her two pet cats a quick pat before heading out the door. Her first appointment was scheduled for 10.30 am, where she would be showing a client named Bob Southall, a rundown, two-story, semi-detached house located at 153 Turnbury Road in Birmingham. Bob had called Shipways two weeks earlier, seeking a list of houses for sale in the
斯蒂芬妮的生活一帆风顺。她喜欢新工作，有一个男朋友和活跃的社交生活，刚刚和朋友预订了两周的暑假。两人计划访问怀特岛，那是英格兰南部一个风景如画的岛屿，斯蒂芬妮小时候经常去那里。当斯蒂芬妮准备好去上班时，她的父母已经出门了。她在出门前轻轻拍了拍两只宠物猫。她的第一个预约安排在上午10点30分，她将在那里向一位名叫鲍勃·索尔豪斯的客户展示一栋位于伯明翰坦伯利路153号的破旧两层半独立式房屋。鲍勃两周前曾致电船坞房地产公司，索取一份
£60,000 price range. He had visited the office in person to collect the list, before sending a letter confirming which house he wanted to visit. This was unusual, as most prospective buyers typically booked their viewings via telephone. Stephanie arrived at the office at 9 am and spent the first part of her morning checking her mail and following up on client inquiries, before driving to meet Bob at the Turnbury Road property. Shortly before noon, Stephanie's manager, Kevin Watts and another colleague, were on their way to a meeting when they drove past 153 Turnbury Road and noticed that Stephanie's car was still parked out the front. They remarked that she'd been at her appointment for an unusually long time.
价格在6万英镑左右的待售房屋列表。他亲自到办公室领取了这份列表，然后寄了一封信确认他想参观哪栋房子。这很不寻常，因为大多数潜在买家通常是通过电话预订看房的。斯蒂芬妮上午9点到达办公室，清晨的早些时候用来检查邮件和跟进客户咨询，然后开车去坦伯利路的房产处与鲍勃见面。中午前不久，斯蒂芬妮的经理凯文·沃茨和另一位同事在去开会的路上开车经过坦伯利路153号，注意到斯蒂芬妮的车仍然停在门前。他们评论说她这次看房的时间异常地长。
20 minutes later, the phone rang at the Shipways office. Receptionist Sylvia Baker answered and a man on the other end stated, Listen, Syl, Stephanie Slater, she's been kidnapped. There will be a ransom note in the post tomorrow. Contact the police or anybody and she'll die. He then hung up. Stunned, Sylvia immediately called Kevin Watts at his meeting and he quickly returned to the office. Stephanie's co-workers called the number Bob Southall had provided, but it turned out to be connected to a phone booth at a petrol station. Kevin and a colleague then hurried to 153 Turnbury Road. Stephanie's car was still parked out the
20分钟后，船坞房地产公司的电话铃响了。接待员西尔维娅·贝克接了电话，那头的一个男人说：“听着，西尔，斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特被绑架了。明天邮局会有一封勒索信。联系警察或任何人，她就会死。”随后他挂断了电话。西尔维娅惊呆了，立即打电话给正在开会的凯文·沃茨，凯文迅速赶回办公室。斯蒂芬妮的同事拨打了鲍勃·索尔豪斯提供的号码，但结果发现那是连接到一家加油站公用电话亭的号码。凯文和一位同事随后匆忙赶往坦伯利路153号。斯蒂芬妮的车仍然停在
front, but the house was empty. In the hallway, they found Stephanie's car keys as well as the keys for the property. On one of the key rings, there were several spots of blood and a single long hair. Kevin phoned the police and uniformed officers were immediately dispatched to the house on Turnbury Road to conduct a search. In the upstairs bathroom and at the top of the stairs, they found drops of blood as well as a larger bloodstain on a wall near the kitchen. Officers interviewed Shipways employees and installed a phone at the office that could record and trace incoming calls. When Stephanie's parents Warren and Betty Slater were notified, they both collapsed in shock and required sedation. They couldn't think of any reason
门前，但房子里空无一人。在过道里，他们找到了斯蒂芬妮的车钥匙以及该房产的钥匙。在其中一串钥匙上，有几个血迹斑点和一根长长的头发。凯文报警了，身穿制服的警官被立即派往坦伯利路的房子进行搜查。在楼上的浴室和楼梯顶部，他们发现了血迹，厨房附近的一面墙上还有一个更大的血迹斑点。警官们走访了船坞房地产公司的员工，并在办公室安装了一部可以记录和追踪来电的电话。当斯蒂芬妮的父母沃伦和贝蒂·斯莱特接到通知时，两人震惊得瘫倒在地，需要镇静剂。他们想不出任何理由
why Stephanie would be targeted, nor did they believe she had any reason to orchestrate her own disappearance. Detectives from the West Midlands police were assigned to the case. And immediately realized it had been a mistake to send uniformed officers in response to the report, as the kidnapper had warned Sylvia not to call the police. The uniformed officers were quickly withdrawn and replaced with undercover investigators. Shortly after 3pm, another call came through at the Shipways office. A man with a northern accent stated, Just listen, Stephanie's dropped her keys to the house in the hall, so go and lock it up. The call was over so fast that it was unable to be recorded.
说明斯蒂芬妮为什么会成为目标，也不相信她有任何理由策划自己的失踪。西米德兰兹警察局的侦探被指派负责此案。并立即意识到派制服警察回应报案是个错误，因为绑架者曾警告西尔维娅不要报警。制服警察迅速撤回，换成了便衣调查人员。下午3点后不久，船坞房地产公司又接到一个电话。一个带有北方口音的男子说：“听着，斯蒂芬妮把房子的钥匙掉在走廊了，去把它锁上。”通话结束得太快，根本无法被录音。
An incident room was set up and a media embargo was enforced to prevent the story from going public. Shipways agreed to pay whatever the kidnapper demanded, and police were granted permission to sort through the post at Birmingham's Royal Mail sorting office, in an attempt to find the ransom letter as soon as possible. At 5am on Thursday, January 23, they found an envelope addressed to Shipways that contained a letter and a micro cassette tape. The letter explained that Stephanie would only be released if Shipways agreed to pay £175,000 in unmarked bills that were free from tracking devices. The micro cassette featured a female voice saying,
警方设立了一个案情室，并实施了媒体禁令，以防止事件公之于众。船坞房地产公司同意支付绑架者要求的任何赎金，警方获准在伯明翰皇家邮政分拣处筛查邮件，试图尽快找到勒索信。1月23日星期四凌晨5点，他们发现了一个寄给船坞房地产公司的信封，里面有一封信和一个微型盒式磁带。信中解释说，只有在船坞房地产公司同意支付17.5万英镑没有追踪装置的旧纸币的情况下，斯蒂芬妮才会被释放。微型磁带里有一个女人的声音在说：
This is Stephanie Slater. The time is 11.45. I can assure you I am okay and unharmed. Providing these instructions are carried out, I will be released on Friday, the 31st of January. She explained that her manager, Kevin Watts, was to deliver the money on Wednesday, January 29. He had to use his own car and would be given instructions at various points along the way. West Midlands police were aware of Julie Darts' murder and the extortion attempt against British Rail and wondered whether Stephanie's disappearance could be connected. The similarities between the three crimes appeared to be mounting. Both Julie and Stephanie's kidnapper had used recorded messages and misspelled the word ransom by adding an E on the end.
“我是斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特。现在时间是11点45分。我可以向你们保证，我很好，没有受伤。只要执行这些指示，我将在1月31日星期五被释放。”她解释说，她的经理凯文·沃茨必须在1月29日星期三交付赎金。他必须使用自己的汽车，并在沿途的各个地点接到指示。西米德兰兹警方了解朱莉·达特的谋杀案以及针对英国铁路公司的勒索未遂事件，并怀疑斯蒂芬妮的失踪是否与此有关。这三起犯罪之间的相似之处似乎越来越多。朱莉和斯蒂芬妮的绑架者都使用了录音信息，并且在拼写“赎金”（ransom）一词时在结尾多加了一个字母E。
Moreover, in all three crimes, the perpetrator provided very specific instructions about how the money was to be bundled. Investigators began carrying out covert operations in the neighbourhood where Stephanie had been abducted. They door-knocked houses on Turnberry Road, explaining that there had been a break-in nearby and asked whether neighbours had seen anything unusual on Wednesday, January 22. One mentioned seeing a red van revving its engine and turning into a laneway to the rear of the houses. Another had noticed a man standing outside of 153 Turnberry Road who appeared to be in his early 50s. He was short and wore a coat with a badge on the left to breast pocket. With little in the way of leads, investigators were forced to
此外，在这三起犯罪中，作案者都就如何捆绑钱款提供了非常具体的指示。调查人员开始在斯蒂芬妮被绑架的社区开展秘密行动。他们敲击坦伯利路各户人家的房门，解释说附近发生了一起入室盗窃案，并询问邻居在1月22日星期三是否看到过任何异常情况。其中一人提到看到一辆红色货车猛踩油门，拐进房屋后方的小巷。另一人注意到一名男子站在坦伯利路153号外面，看起来刚满50岁左右。他个子不高，穿着一件左胸口袋上有徽章的外套。由于几乎没有什么线索，调查人员被迫
wait and see whether the kidnapper would make contact again. At 2pm on Sunday, January 26, four days after Stephanie had vanished, the phone rang at her parents' home. Recording equipment had been set up in anticipation of this moment and Stephanie's father, Warren, immediately started taping the call. A male voice on the other end told Warren to listen and then played a pre-recorded message featuring Stephanie's voice. She said, Hello, it's Stephanie here. They've allowed me to make a message to you, just to let you know that I'm alright and unharmed. I hear that West Bromwich Albion lost yesterday to Swansea 3-2. I want you to know that I love you. I'm not to say too much,
等待并观察绑架者是否会再次联系。1月26日星期日晚上2点，在斯蒂芬妮失踪四天后，她父母家里的电话响了。为了迎接这一刻，录音设备已经设置好，斯蒂芬妮的父亲沃伦立即开始录下通话。另一端的男声叫沃伦听着，然后播放了一段带有斯蒂芬妮声音的预录信息。她说：“喂，我是斯蒂芬妮。他们允许我给你留个言，只是为了让你知道我很好，没有受伤。我听说西布朗维奇队昨天以3比2输给了斯旺西。我想让你知道我爱你们。我不能说太多，
and whatever the outcome, I'll always love you. Look after the cats for me. The results from the recent football match indicated that Stephanie was still alive. Her parents were both relieved and distraught, while investigators believed that if they followed the kidnappers' demands, they might have a chance of bringing Stephanie home safely. Stephanie's manager Kevin Watts agreed to help, and investigators provided him with strategies to speak with the kidnapper to minimize threats to his own safety. As the kidnapper had already demonstrated that he was capable of traveling throughout the country, 1,000 detectives from the Midlands Police Forces, Scotland Yard and the Metropolitan Police
无论结果如何，我都会永远爱你们。替我照顾好猫。”这场最新足球比赛的结果表明斯蒂芬妮仍然活着。她的父母既感到解脱又感到心烦意乱，而调查人员则认为，如果他们遵从绑架者的要求，他们或许有机会将斯蒂芬妮安全带回家。斯蒂芬妮的经理凯文·沃茨同意协助，调查人员为他提供了与绑架者对话的策略，以将对自己安全的威胁降到最低。由于绑架者已经表现出他有能力在全国各地穿梭，来自米德兰兹警察部队、苏格兰场和伦敦警察厅的1000名侦探
were enlisted to be positioned throughout various motorways during the operation. Investigators would follow Kevin from all directions, with backup ready just in case. Four female detectives would be on standby to care for Stephanie if she was returned safely, while another 30 officers were prepared to spring into action if she was found to be deceased. Shortly before 5pm on Tuesday, January 28, the day before the ransom drop, the phone rang at Shipways Estate Agency. It was the kidnapper demanding to speak to Kevin. He asked if Kevin had the money, and in response, Kevin inquired who was calling. The kidnapper responded impatiently,
被征召在行动期间部署在各个高速公路上。调查人员将从四面八方跟随凯文，后备力量随时准备以防万一。四名女侦探将待命照顾安全归来的斯蒂芬妮，而另外30名警官则准备在发现她已经遇害时立即采取行动。1月28日星期二下午5点前不久，即交付赎金的前一天，船坞房地产公司的电话铃响了。那是绑架者要求与凯文通话。他问凯文有没有钱，作为回应，凯文反问是谁打来的。绑架者不耐烦地回答：
never mind, have you got the money for tomorrow. Kevin confirmed that he was getting it, and the kidnapper told him to expect a message at 3 o'clock the following day. The next morning, Kevin said goodbye to his wife and daughters, using his finger to write, I love you in the air, before getting into his car. At the office, he put a bulletproof vest on beneath his work suit. A two-way radio was installed in his vehicle, and the ransom money was delivered to the office in a sports bag that had a tracking device sewn into the lining. He was to keep the bag with him at all times, so that the police could constantly track his whereabouts. At 3.25pm, the kidnapper
“少废话，明天你要的钱准备好了吗？”凯文确认他正在筹备，绑架者告诉他第二天3点等候消息。第二天早上，凯文向妻子和女儿告别，用手指在空中写下“我爱你”，然后上了车。在办公室里，他在工作西装下面穿了一件防弹衣。他的车里安装了一个双向对讲机，赎金被装在一个运动包里送到了办公室，该运动包的衬里缝有追踪装置。他必须时刻把包带在身边，以便警察能够随时追踪他的行踪。下午3点25分，绑架者
called and instructed Kevin to go to the railway station in Glossop, a town almost 98 miles north of Birmingham. There, he was to head to the payphone in the station's entrance hall, where the kidnapper would call to provide further instructions at 7 o'clock. Kevin departed for Glossop with undercover officers trailing behind. As he drove, he used the two-way radio to keep the police informed about the route he was taking. He arrived at Glossop railway station shortly before 7pm, and waited nervously by the phone booth the kidnapper had described. Eventually, the kidnapper called and told Kevin to leave the station, turn right, and go to another phone box about 200 yards away. There, he would find
打电话指示凯文前往格洛索普的火车站，那是一个位于伯明翰以北约98英里的城镇。在那里，他要前往车站入口大厅的公用电话亭，绑架者将在7点打电话提供进一步指示。凯文出发前往格洛索普，便衣警察紧随其后。开车时，他用双向对讲机向警方通报他所走的路线。他在晚上7点前不久到达格洛索普火车站，紧张地守候在绑架者描述的电话亭旁。最终，绑架者打来电话，指示凯文离开车站，向右转，去大约200码外的另一个电话亭。在那里，他会找到
written instructions taped beneath a shelf. Kevin followed these orders and found an envelope in the phone booth marked with the letter A. Inside, was a typed note directing him to drive 22 miles east towards the town of Dodworth, where another letter was waiting in a phone booth. Kevin got back in his car and started driving, but within a minute, heavy fog fell all around him, making it difficult to see. The limited visibility hindered his progress, but he made it to the isolated phone booth by 8.15. A note inside pointed him towards an off-road lane 150 yards away and warned, this route will show if you are being followed. Once there, Kevin was to look for a red and white traffic cone near a small building.
贴在架子底下的书面指示。凯文照办了，并在电话亭里找到了一个标有字母A的信封。里面是一张打字纸便条，指示他向东驱车22英里前往多德沃思镇，另一个信条在另一个电话亭里等着。凯文回到车里开始开车，但不到一分钟，浓雾四面八方笼罩下来，让人难以看清。有限的能见度阻碍了他的进展，但他在8点15分到达了那个孤立的电话亭。里面的一张便条指引他前往150码外的一条越野小路，并警告说：“这条路线将显示你是否被跟踪。”到了那里，凯文要寻找一个小建筑附近的一个红白相间的交通锥。
There would be a bag next to the cone, which he was to place the money into. Kevin returned to his car again and turned left onto the lane, passing a small wooden sign that read, Shipways. The track was rough and framed by hedges and low stone walls, but he soon spotted a shed with a cone and a large black bag in front of it. Kevin pulled over, griped the bag and stuffed the cash inside. He found a note directing him to continue to the end of the lane and then on to another pay phone several miles away, where another note was waiting. Kevin kept driving forward, noticing that the stone walls on either side suddenly loomed much
锥体旁边会有一个包，他要把钱放进那个包里。凯文再次回到车里，左转进入小路，经过一块写着“船坞”的小木牌。这条土路坑洼不平，两侧被树篱和低矮的石墙环绕，但他很快发现了一个棚子，前面立着一个锥体和一个大黑包。凯文把车停下，抓起包，把现金塞了进去。他发现一张便条，指示他继续开到小路尽头，然后开到几英里外的另一个公用电话，那里还有另一张便条在等待。凯文继续往前开，注意到两侧的石墙突然显得高大得多。
higher. Within 300 yards, he unexpectedly encountered another cone with a stenciled message attached. It explained that a wooden tray with a sensor inside was perched on one of the walls. Kevin was instructed to place the bag with the money in the tray, and if the sensor didn't buzz, he could leave the money and go. Kevin walked over to the tray, noticing a silver rectangular device in one of its corners. He jammed the bag inside and was relieved when the sensor didn't make a sound. Nervously, he then headed back to his car. Meanwhile, the investigators who were monitoring Kevin's movements had struggled to find a parallel route along the narrow lane and had lost contact with the tracking signal
在300码以内，他意外地遇到了另一个带有模板印刷信息的锥体。上面解释说，一面墙上架着一个带有内部传感器的木盘。凯文被指示将装有钱的包放在盘子里，如果传感器没有蜂鸣，他就可以放下钱离开。凯文走向托盘，注意到其中一个角落有一个银色的长方形设备。他把包塞了进去，当传感器没有发出声音时，他松了一口气。随后，他紧张地走回自己的车里。与此同时，监测凯文动向的调查人员沿着狭窄的小路寻找平行路线时遇到了困难，并失去了与
that had been fitted into his bag. By the time Kevin delivered the money, they had lost sight of him altogether. Kevin had used the two-way radio to let the police know that he was about to hand over the cash, but a technical problem had prevented them from receiving the message. As Kevin drove away from the drop-off site, he used the two-way radio again to inform police that he'd successfully dropped off the money. This time, his message went through. Investigators were horrified to learn that they'd lost contact with their courier at the most crucial moment, as it meant the kidnapper had likely managed to escape with the money.
装在他包里的追踪信号的联系。当凯文交付赎金时，他们已经完全失去了他的踪迹。凯文曾使用双向对讲机让警察知道他即将交出现金，但技术问题阻止了他们收到消息。当凯文驶离交货地点时，他再次使用双向对讲机通知警察他已经成功交出了赎金。这一次，他的消息发出去了。调查人员惊恐地得知他们在最关键的时刻失去了与信使的联系，这意味着绑架者很带着钱成功逃跑了。
Worse still, they had no idea where Stephanie was, or if they'd just lost their only chance to save her life. When West Yorkshire detectives heard that their prime suspect for Julie Dartsmurder had slipped through West Midlands Police's comprehensive and elaborate sting, they were furious. Investigators said about detaining and interrogating everyone they encountered in proximity of the drop-off zone, but there was no sign of the kidnapper or of Stephanie Slater. Eventually, at 11.30pm, police reluctantly held a press conference to announce that their operation had failed. Although the media embargo on the story was still being enforced, investigators admitted the money had been handed over, but they had not managed to recover Stephanie.
更糟糕的是，他们根本不知道斯蒂芬妮在哪里，也不知道他们是否刚刚失去了拯救她生命的唯一机会。当西约克郡的侦探们听到他们对朱莉·达特谋杀案的主要嫌疑人从西米德兰兹警察局周密复杂的钓鱼执法中溜走时，他们愤怒极了。调查人员着手拘留和审讯他们在交货区附近遇到的所有人，但没有绑架者或斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特的踪迹。最终，在晚上11点30分，警方不情愿地举行了一场新闻发布会，宣布他们的行动失败了。尽管该故事的媒体禁令仍在实施，但调查人员承认钱已经交出，但他们未能寻回斯蒂芬妮。
Detective Inspector Adrian Bowers had been tasked with looking after Stephanie's parents while the operation was carried out and was waiting with them in their family home. The past eight days had been incredibly distressing for Warren and Betty Slater, and the news that Stephanie had not been been saved during the operation further added to their grief. At 12.50am, there was a loud banging at the Slater's front door, accompanied by the doorbell ringing. Detective Bowers raced to answer it and found a dishevelled looking young woman whom he didn't recognise standing on the doorstep. Warren Slater rushed up from behind, pushed the detective out of the way and pulled the woman into the house, shouting to his wife. It's our Stephanie. She's home.
侦探督察阿德里安·鲍尔斯在行动期间负责照顾斯蒂芬妮的父母，并一直在他们的家中陪着他们。过去八天对沃伦和贝蒂·斯莱特来说极其痛苦，而斯蒂芬妮在行动中未能获救的消息进一步加深了他们的悲伤。凌晨12点50分，斯莱特家前门传来一阵剧烈的敲门声，伴随着门铃声。鲍尔斯侦探冲过去应门，发现门阶上站着一个衣衫褴褛、他认不出来的年轻女子。沃伦·斯莱特从后面冲上来，把侦探推开，把女子拉进屋里，对妻子大喊：“是我们的斯蒂芬妮。她回家了。”
Stephanie's parents were eager to embrace their daughter, but Detective Bowers held them back, explaining there might be crucial evidence on her body. He asked Stephanie where her kidnapper was, to which she responded, oh he's long gone. It turned out that the kidnapper had driven Stephanie home himself, dropping her roughly 200 feet from her house. There had been no security detail outside, meaning the kidnapper had managed to elude police twice that night. Investigators and doctors arrived at the Slater's home, and Stephanie underwent a physical examination. Though confused and disoriented, she didn't have any serious injuries. She revealed she had been blindfolded for a long period of time, and the doctors
斯蒂芬妮的父母急于拥抱他们的女儿，但鲍尔斯侦探拦住了他们，解释说她的身上可能藏有关键证据。他问斯蒂芬妮她的绑架者在哪里，她回答说：“哦，他早就走了。”原来绑架者自己开车把斯蒂芬妮送回家，把她放在离她家大约200英尺的地方。外面没有安保人员，这意味着绑架者当晚成功两次躲过了警察。调查人员和医生抵达斯蒂芬妮的家，斯蒂芬妮接受了身体检查。尽管感到困惑和迷失方向，她并没有受到任何重伤。她透露自己被蒙住眼睛很长时间，医生
confirmed that her eyesight was temporarily damaged as a result. Blood and hair samples were taken, and physical evidence was collected from underneath her fingernails. Her clothing was also taken into evidence. Stephanie denied that any sexual assault had taken place, meaning that it wasn't necessary for doctors to conduct a rape kit. After being allowed to shower, she was transported to a private hospital for monitoring, where her parents were allowed to stay in an adjoining room. When she learned that her kidnapper was also suspected of having murdered Julie Dott, she was overcome with grief at the thought of what Julie had endured.
证实她的视力因此暂时受损。提取了血液和毛发样本，并从她指甲下方收集了物证。她的衣服也被作为物证带走。斯蒂芬妮否认发生过任何性侵犯，这意味着医生没有必要进行强奸证据提取。在被允许洗澡后，她被送到一家私立医院进行监测，她的父母被允许住在隔壁的房间里。当她得知她的绑架者还涉嫌谋杀朱莉·达特时，一想到朱莉所遭受的折磨，她便悲痛欲绝。
The eight-day media embargo was finally lifted, and the next morning, Stephanie's story featured on breakfast news and radio programs throughout the country. West Midlands police assistant Chief Constable Phil Thomas thanked the press for their cooperation throughout the operation, and said that while the kidnapper had escaped with £175,000, police had achieved their primary objective of bringing Stephanie home. He stated, quote, We can now openly get on with the investigation to catch this man. Our inquiries are now well in hand, and we have gained a lot of information which we didn't have before. The media interest in the story was intense, and later that afternoon, Stephanie appeared at
为期八天的媒体禁令终于解除，第二天早晨，斯蒂芬妮的故事登上了全国各地的早间新闻和广播节目。西米德兰兹警察局助理总警司菲尔·托马斯感谢媒体在整个行动中的合作，并表示虽然绑架者带着17.5万英镑逃跑了，但警方实现了将斯蒂芬妮带回家的首要目标。他声明道：“我们现在可以公开推进抓捕这个男人的调查。我们的调查进展顺利，并且我们获得了许多以前没有掌握的信息。”公众对这个故事的媒体兴趣非常浓厚，那天下午晚些时候，斯蒂芬妮出现在
a press conference to answer questions about her ordeal. When asked how she felt upon realizing she had been abducted, she stated, I'd call it sheer terror. You can't put that sort of feeling into words unless you've actually been through it. Stephanie said she was eager to thank her manager Kevin Watts in person, and hoped that she could return to her normal life as soon as possible. Following the press conference, Stephanie returned to the hospital, where she spent the next 10 days providing evidence about her ordeal to three female officers who were specially trained in debriefing victims. Her recall was excellent, and she managed to provide a detailed account of the events that unfolded after she met the man claiming to be named Bob Southall
一场新闻发布会上，回答关于她遭遇的问题。当被问及意识到自己被绑架时的感受时，她说：“我会称之为纯粹的恐惧。除非你真正经历过，否则你无法用言语表达那种感觉。”斯蒂芬妮表示她渴望当面向经理凯文·沃茨致谢，并希望尽快恢复正常生活。新闻发布会结束后，斯蒂芬妮返回医院，在接下来的10天里，她向三位专门接受过审讯受害者培训的女警官提供了关于她遭遇的证据。她的记忆力非常好，并设法对遇到自称叫鲍勃·索尔豪斯的男子后发生的事情做了详细描述。
at 153 Turnbury Road. When Stephanie arrived at the address, Bob was already standing by the front door. She described him as aged between 40 and 55, with an average to stocky build and a tanned complexion. He had been wearing thick black-framed glasses and a jacket that had a badge picturing a train on its left pocket. He spoke with a northern accent, indicating he wasn't local to Birmingham. When they entered the property, Bob asked a few questions about the house, but didn't appear particularly interested. As they headed upstairs to see the second story, Bob pointed to a window and inquired whether it was double-glazed. Stephanie replied that it was.
当斯蒂芬妮到达该地址时，鲍勃已经站在前门旁了。她形容他年龄在40岁到55岁之间，中等身材到壮实，肤色晒黑。他戴着一副厚重的黑框眼镜，夹克左口袋上有一个印有火车图案的徽章。他说话带有北方口音，表明他不是伯明翰本地人。当他们进入屋内时，鲍勃问了一些关于房子的简单问题，但似乎并没有特别感兴趣。当他们上楼去看二楼时，鲍勃指着一扇窗户，询问是否是双层玻璃。斯蒂芬妮回答说是的。
Stephanie waited nearby while Bob explored the upstairs rooms. As he entered the bathroom, Stephanie began to walk back downstairs, but Bob suddenly pointed at the wall opposite him and asked, what's that up there? Stephanie went into the bathroom and realised he was pointing at a hook, which she explained was to hang a towel on. She turned around to leave, but Bob suddenly flew towards her. He was holding a 10- to 12-inch knife in one hand and a long, flat chisel with a hook in the other. A struggle ensued and Stephanie received small nicks to her face from the knife. She grabbed both weapons and managed to bend the chisel, rendering it useless. Stephanie screamed and Bob attempted to cover her mouth with his hand. He then jumped on her and grabbed her long
斯蒂芬妮在附近等待，而鲍勃则在楼上的房间里探索。当他进入浴室时，斯蒂芬妮开始走回楼下，但鲍勃突然指着他正对面的墙问：“那上面是什么？”斯蒂芬妮走进浴室，意识到他指的是一个挂钩，她解释那是用来挂毛巾的。她转身离开，但鲍勃突然向她扑来。他一只手拿着一把10到12英寸长的刀，另一只手拿着一把带钩的长平凿子。双方发生厮打，斯蒂芬妮的脸被刀划出了小伤口。她抓住两把武器，设法把凿子弯曲，使其失去作用。斯蒂芬妮尖叫起来，鲍勃试图用手捂住她的嘴。接着他扑向她，从后面抓住她的长
hair from behind, wrenching her head back and pushing her over the side of the bathtub. Stephanie caught a glimpse of herself in the mirror and saw that Bob was holding a knife to her throat. He threatened to cut her throat if she started screaming, to which Stephanie responded. All right, calm down. You've got me. Don't kill me. Please don't kill me. Please remember, I'm human. Bob bound Stephanie's wrists together with what appeared to be rope from a washing line and placed a noose around her neck made from the same material. He forced her downstairs, yelling angrily whenever she looked directly at him. At the bottom of the stairs, he blindfolded and gagged Stephanie using her own scarf,
头发，猛地把她的头向后拉，把她推过浴缸边缘。斯蒂芬妮在镜子里瞥见自己，看到鲍勃正拿着一把刀抵着她的喉咙。他威胁说如果她开始尖叫就割断她的喉咙，斯蒂芬妮回应道：“好了，冷静点。你抓住我了。别杀我。求求你别杀我。请记住，我是个人。”鲍勃用看起来像是晾衣绳的东西把斯蒂芬妮的手腕绑在一起，并用同样的材料在她脖子上套了一个绞索。他强行把她拖下楼，每当她直视他时他就愤怒地大喊。在楼梯底部，他用她自己的围巾蒙住她的眼睛并塞住嘴，
then tied her legs with rope just below the knees. He then steered her through the back of the house and into the garage, where he forced her into a vehicle at knife point. Stephanie was made to lie down on the passenger seat, which had been moved into a reclining position. Her face was then covered with a blanket and a line of rope was tied across her neck to restrict her from sitting up. Bob held a knife to her stomach and started driving. In order to determine where they were going, Stephanie focused on noises, the quality of the roads and the turns Bob was taking. He eventually pulled over in a quiet, isolated area and forced Stephanie to record the ransom message that he later sent to her employers. He also explained
然后用绳子把她的膝盖下方绑起来。接着他引导她穿过房子后方进入车库，在刀尖逼迫下将她强行塞进一辆车里。斯蒂芬妮被迫躺在已经调至后倾位置的乘客座椅上。她的脸随后被一条毯子盖住，一根绳子横绑在她的脖子上以限制她坐起来。鲍勃拿着刀抵着她的肚子开始开车。为了确定他们要去哪里，斯蒂芬妮专注于声音、道路质量以及鲍勃转弯的方向。他最终在一个安静、偏僻的地方靠边停车，强迫斯蒂芬妮录制了后来发给她雇主的赎金信息。他还解释说
that his name wasn't really Bob, but instructed Stephanie to continue calling him that, to make things easier. By evening, they reached a rough dirt track. Bob parked the car and guided Stephanie along a gravel path. He pushed what sounded like a metallic sliding door and led Stephanie into a room with a stone floor where he tied her to a wooden chair. He left the room and returned shortly after with some chips for her to eat. He then forced her to change into men's clothing and remarked, I hope you're not claustrophobic. Bob explained he was going to place Stephanie inside a box that was placed inside another box. She was forced to lie down and shuffle feet first into a long, narrow container which required her to twist her body into an uncomfortable corkscrew
他的名字其实不叫鲍勃，但指示斯蒂芬妮继续这样叫他，以让事情变得简单些。到了晚上，他们到达了一条崎岖的土路。鲍勃把车停下，引导斯蒂芬妮沿着一条砂石小路前进。他推开一扇听起来像金属推拉门的东西，把斯蒂芬妮领进一个铺着石头地面的房间，并在那里把她绑在一把木椅上。他离开了房间，不久后带着一些薯条回来给她吃。接着他强行让她换上男装并评论道：“希望你没有幽闭恐惧症。”鲍勃解释说他要把斯蒂芬妮放进一个套在另一个盒子里的箱子里。她被迫躺下，双脚率先挪进一个又长又窄的容器里，这要求她将身体扭成一个令人不舒服的螺旋塞子
position. Once she was in, Bob tied Stephanie's handcuffed wrists to a metal bar above her head and warned that if she pulled on the bar, boulders placed above would fall down and crush her. He also placed a wire inside the box which he explained was attached to electrodes that would shock Stephanie if she moved. Bob told Stephanie he couldn't understand why she was so calm to which she responded, I'm not calm, I'm frightened to death. Bob closed the lid over the top of her head and said, See you in the morning then. Stephanie spent the night in physical agony. It was freezing cold and her body was in pain from the awkward, restricted position she'd been forced into. Terrified, she lay awake throughout
姿势。一进去，鲍勃就把斯蒂芬妮被手铐铐住的手腕绑在她头顶上方的一根金属栏杆上，并警告说如果她拉扯栏杆，上面放置的巨石就会掉下来把她压碎。他还在箱子里放了一根电线，解释说它连接着电极，如果她动一下就会电击她。鲍勃告诉斯蒂芬妮他搞不懂她为什么这么冷静，她回答说：“我不冷静，我吓死了。”鲍勃盖上她头顶上方的盖子说：“那明天见喽。”斯蒂芬妮在极度痛苦中度过了这个夜晚。外面冰天雪地，她被迫保持着别扭、受限的姿势，全身酸痛。她惊恐万状地躺着清醒了一整
the night, convinced she would die from suffocation or hypothermia. At her most distraught point, she noticed a speck of light that appeared to grow and move towards her. As it came closer, Stephanie realized it resembled the face of Jesus Christ. As she was not a religious person, the vision took her by surprise and she wondered whether she had died. The following morning, music started playing from a nearby radio. By this stage, Stephanie's entire body was wracked with excruciating pain and her extremities were numb. Bob opened the box and seemed surprised to find her in such agony. He removed Stephanie from the box and sat her onto a chair, rubbing her arms in an attempt to lessen the pain. After giving her a cup of tea and some
夜，确信自己会因窒息或低体温而死。在她最崩溃的时刻，她注意到一个微弱的光点似乎在变大并向她移动。随着它越来越近，斯蒂芬妮意识到它看起来像耶稣基督的面容。由于她不是一个有宗教信仰的人，这个幻象让她大吃一惊，她甚至怀疑自己是不是已经死了。第二天早上，附近的一台收音机开始播放音乐。此时，斯蒂芬妮全身剧痛难忍，四肢麻木。鲍勃打开箱子，看到她处于如此痛苦之中似乎感到很惊讶。他把斯蒂芬妮从箱子里抱出来，扶她坐在椅子上，揉搓着她的手臂试图减轻疼痛。在给她倒了一杯茶和一些
porridge, he explained that his plan was to keep her hostage until the following Wednesday, January 29, when he would collect his ransom money. If she behaved, Bob told Stephanie she would be home within a week. Instead of returning her to the box, Bob then allowed Stephanie to stay on a mattress on the floor while he went to work, provided she didn't make any noise or attempt an escape. After he had left, Stephanie began reflecting on Bob's behavior. Although he had been threatening and violent, he had also shown a more humane side and Stephanie wondered if she could appeal to this part of his personality. Deciding her best chance at survival was to be compliant and polite, she resolved to put her strong people skills to use.
粥后，他解释说他的计划是把她扣为人质，直到接下来的1月29日星期三，那时他将去取赎金。如果她听话，鲍勃告诉斯蒂芬妮她会在一周内回家。鲍勃没有把她放回箱子里，而是让斯蒂芬妮待在地板上的床垫上，自己去上班了，前提是她不能制造噪音或试图逃跑。他离开后，斯蒂芬妮开始反思鲍勃的行为。虽然他一直充满威胁且具有暴力倾向，但他也表现出了较为人性化的一面，斯蒂芬妮琢磨着自己是否可以利用他性格中的这一面。她认定自己生存的最大机会是顺从而礼貌，于是下定决心发挥自己出色的社交能力。
Over the following week, Bob returned every morning and evening to give Stephanie food and let her use the toilet. At night, he would also back into the box. During his visits, Stephanie attempted to humanize herself by chatting with Bob about the TV programs she liked to watch. She told him about her boyfriend, whom her mother hoped she would marry one day. On one occasion, Bob brought a German shepherd puppy with him and Stephanie revealed her love of animals. She also confided that she had been adopted at six months old because her parents were unable to conceive children and Bob appeared moved by this revelation. Although Stephanie was kept blindfolded and bound a majority of the time,
在接下来的一个星期里，鲍勃每天早晚都会回来给斯蒂芬妮送食物，并让她去上厕所。到了晚上，他还会把她塞回箱子里。在访问期间，斯蒂芬妮试图通过和鲍勃闲聊她喜欢看的电视节目来展现自己的人情味。她向他讲述了自己的男朋友，她的母亲希望她有一天能嫁给他。有一次，鲍勃带来了一只德国牧羊犬幼犬，斯蒂芬妮表现出她对动物的喜爱。她还向他吐露，因为父母无法生育，她六个月大时就被收养了，鲍勃似乎被这个透露的信息打动了。虽然斯蒂芬妮大部分时间都被蒙着眼睛且绑着，
she managed to pay close attention to her surroundings. During her first day in captivity, she heard muffled voices nearby, followed by a short ringing sound and then silence. This pattern repeated several times and Stephanie realized she was likely being held out the back of a store. The sound of an electric saw and banging led her to believe it could be an engineering workshop. In addition, she knew there was a microwave nearby as it made a dinging sound every time Bob made her porridge. A radio was also close by, which played all day and was permanently tuned to BBC's Radio 2 channel. Stephanie also heard a bell on what sounded like an old-fashioned cash register and the ringing of a rotary-style phone.
但她设法密切注意周围的环境。在被囚禁的第一天，她听到附近有沉闷的人声，接着是一声短促的铃声，然后是一片寂静。这种模式重复了好几次，斯蒂芬妮意识到她很可能是被关在一家商店的后头。电锯声和敲击声让她觉得这可能是一个工程车间。此外，她知道附近有一个微波炉，因为每当鲍勃给她做粥时它都会发出“叮”的声音。附近还有一个收音机，整天播放，并且永久调到了BBC的2号广播频道。斯蒂芬妮还听到类似老式收银机的铃声以及转盘式电话的铃声。
The sound of trucks, lorries and trains could also be heard regularly passing through the neighborhood. During one conversation, Bob told Stephanie that he was carrying out the ransom scheme with a male accomplice, whom he referred to as his mate. He described the man as a nasty piece of work and told Stephanie she was lucky not to be stuck with him. Bob appeared to grow somewhat fond of Stephanie and repeatedly promised that she would be going home. Yet, he also appeared to take pleasure in scaring her. On one occasion, Stephanie told a joke that made Bob laugh, after which he remarked, I'll have to get rid of that bin now. When Stephanie asked which bin he was referring to,
卡车、大货车和火车驶过社区的声音也能经常听到。在一次谈话中，鲍勃告诉斯蒂芬妮，他是和一个男同谋一起实施这起绑架勒索计划的，他称那人为他的“搭档”。他形容那个人是个极其讨厌的家伙，并告诉斯蒂芬妮她很幸运没有被那个家伙缠上。鲍勃似乎对斯蒂芬妮产生了一些好感，并一再承诺她会回家。然而，他也似乎从吓唬她中寻找乐趣。有一次，斯蒂芬妮讲了一个笑话把鲍勃逗笑了，之后他评论道：“我现在得把那个垃圾桶扔了。”当斯蒂芬妮问他指的是哪个垃圾桶时，
Bob explained there was a plastic wheelie bin in the corner that he had planned to dispose of her body in. On Sunday, January 26, Bob made Stephanie record a message that he could play for her parents. He had her mention the result of the recent West Bromwich Albion vs Swansea football match to verify that she was still alive. The next day, he confirmed that she would be going home on Wednesday, January 29. On Stephanie's final night in captivity, Bob let her sleep on the mattress instead of inside the box. On the morning of Wednesday, January 29, Bob told Stephanie he would be collecting the ransom money from her manager Kevin Watts that night and would be back to release her between 8 and 9pm. He then remarked, I was thinking that
鲍勃解释说，角落里有一个塑料带轮垃圾桶，他原本打算把她的尸体处理在里面。1926年1月26日星期日，鲍勃让斯蒂芬妮录制了一条他可以放给她父母听的留言。他让她提及最近西布朗维奇与斯旺西足球比赛的结果，以证明她还活着。第二天，他确认她将在1月29日星期三回家。在斯蒂芬妮被囚禁的最后一晚，鲍勃让她睡在床垫上，而不是箱子里面。1月29日星期三早上，鲍勃告诉斯蒂芬妮，他今晚将从她的经理凯文·沃茨那里收取赎金，并会在晚上8点到9点之间回来释放她。接着他评论说，我当时在想
it would be nice to have a photograph of you, you know, something to remember you by. He told Stephanie to remove her blindfold but keep her eyes closed while he snapped a picture of her. Stephanie was then secured back into the box where she remained for the rest of the day. The radio was kept on, allowing her to keep track of the time via the hourly news bulletins. 9pm eventually came and went with no sign of Bob and Stephanie began to worry that he wasn't coming back after all. She became increasingly panicked that she would be left to die a slow, painful death alone in captivity. To escape such a fate, she contemplated taking her own life by smothering her face with the duvet that had been left inside the box with her. At 10.45pm, Bob finally returned.
有一张你的照片会很好，你知道的，留个纪念。他让斯蒂芬妮摘下眼罩，但要闭上眼睛，同时他给她拍了一张照片。随后，斯蒂芬妮被重新固定在箱子里，并在那里度过了当天的剩余时间。收音机一直开着，让她可以通过每小时一次的新闻简报掌握时间。晚上9点最终到来又过去，却不见鲍勃的踪影，斯蒂芬妮开始担心他终究不会回来了。她越来越恐慌，担心自己会被独自留在囚禁中，迎来缓慢而痛苦的死亡。为了逃避这样的命运，她盘算着把塞在箱子里的羽绒被捂在脸上来结束自己的生命。晚上10点45分，鲍勃终于回来了。
He released Stephanie, had her change into new clothes and reassured her that he was taking her home. His initial plan was to leave her at a police station or a phone box but he drove her back to Birmingham instead and dropped her off near her home. Before he left, he asked for a kiss goodbye. After being blindfolded and restricted for over a week, Stephanie found it difficult to see and walk, but she managed to stumble home, where she was finally reunited with her parents. The police were impressed by the level of detail in Stephanie's recollections and said about having create an impression of the perpetrator. Meanwhile, an investigation of the money drop site revealed that the narrow lane with large stone walls that Kevin had been sent to was actually a bridge
他释放了斯蒂芬妮，让她换上新衣服，并向她保证他正带她回家。他最初的计划是将她留在警察局或公用电话亭，但他却开车把她送回伯明翰，并在她家附近把她放下。在他离开之前，他索要了一个吻作为告别。在被蒙住双眼并限制自由一个多星期后，斯蒂芬妮发现自己很难看清东西和走路，但她还是设法踉跄着走回家，在那里她终于与父母团聚了。警方对斯蒂芬妮回忆中的细节水平印象深刻，并讨论了如何拼凑出作案者的印象。与此同时，对藏钱地点的调查显示，凯文被派往的那个带有巨大石墙的狭窄小巷其实是一座桥
above an abandoned railway line. Underneath the bridge, officers recovered a rectangular device that had been painted silver as well as the tray that Kevin had placed the money in, which was a wooden drawer with a length of washing line attached. It appeared that the kidnapper had waited under the bridge, then dragged the drawer with the money in it down after Kevin had left. Investigators theorised that he may have escaped on a motorbike to avoid police roadblocks. The site of the abandoned railway line was part of a country walking trail, known as the Dover Valley Trail. It was just three miles down the track from the bridge,
废弃铁路线之上的桥梁。在桥下，警员们找回了一个被喷成银色的矩形装置，以及凯文放钱的托盘，那是一个连着一段洗衣绳的木抽屉。看来绑架者一直等在桥下，然后在凯文离开后把装着钱的抽屉拖了下去。调查人员推测他可能是骑摩托车逃跑的，以避开警方的路障。废弃铁路线的遗址是一条乡村步行小径的一部分，被称为多弗山谷小径。它距离那座桥沿着轨道只有三英里，
where the painted brick and false incendiary device were found in relation to Julie Dart's case. The two cases were formally linked and West Yorkshire Assistant Chief Constable Tom Cook was appointed as the head of the investigation. Stephanie's neighbours were questioned to see if they'd noticed anything unusual on the night of her return. A spray painter named Les Barnaby recalled that he'd been watching a film in bed around 1am when he heard the sound of a car engine revving outside. He looked out the window and saw a red Austin Metro in the street below. It was old and muddy and the passenger door was slightly open. After a minute, a young, disheveled-looking woman stumbled backwards out of the car and
在那里发现了与朱莉·达特案相关的涂漆砖块和假燃烧装置。这两起案件被正式并案，西约克郡助理警察局长汤姆·库克被任命为调查负责人。警方盘问了斯蒂芬妮的邻居，看他们在她回家的当晚是否注意到任何异常。一名叫莱斯·巴纳比的喷漆工回忆说，凌晨1点左右，他正躺在床上看电影，听到外面有汽车发动机轰鸣的声音。他向窗外望去，看到街下停着一辆红色的奥斯汀·梅特罗汽车。它又旧又泥泞，副驾驶的车门微微敞开着。一分钟后，一个年轻、衣衫褴褛的女人从车里倒着摔了出来，
staggered down the street in an awkward run. On the evening of Tuesday, February 4, six days after Stephanie's return, police released the first sketch of the suspect. It depicted a middle-aged white male with short dark hair wearing square, black-framed glasses. His face was broad with a square forehead and a straight nose. Within an hour of going public, more than 500 people phoned tips in to the police, but none generated any promising leads. Assistant Chief Constable Tom Cook told the media he was almost expecting to hear from the kidnapper directly. Quote, perhaps he might like to boast about it if he feels he has been successful.
沿着街道踉踉跄跄地跑着。2月4日星期二晚上，即斯蒂芬妮回来六天后，警方发布了嫌疑人的第一张素描。画像描绘了一名中年白人男性，留着短黑发，戴着方形黑框眼镜。他的脸很宽，额头方正，鼻子挺直。在公开后不到一个小时内，有500多人打电话向警方提供线索，但没有一条产生任何有前景的线索。助理警察局长汤姆·库克对媒体表示，他几乎正期待着直接听到绑架者的消息。他说：“或许如果他觉得自己已经得逞，他会想要炫耀一下。”
On Thursday, February 6, a letter arrived at the offices of the BBC, Yorkshire Television, the Sun and News of the World newspapers, the West Midlands and West Yorkshire Police, and at the workplace of Julie Dart's mother. It claimed to be from the kidnapper who admitted to abducting Stephanie, but denied murdering Julie or blackmailing British Rail. He wanted to clarify this out of concern for Stephanie's well-being as he had previously told her that he'd never killed anyone and was worried about how she might feel if she thought he had. The letter read,
2月6日星期星期四，一封信件送达了英国广播公司、《约克郡电视台》、《太阳报》和《世界新闻报》的报社办公室、西米德兰兹郡及西约克郡警察局，以及朱莉·达特母亲的工作场所。信中声称来自绑架者，他承认绑架了斯蒂芬妮，但否认谋杀朱莉或勒索英国铁路公司。他想澄清这一点是出于对斯蒂芬妮福祉的担忧，因为他之前曾告诉过她他从未杀过任何人，并且担心如果她以为他杀了人，她心里会怎么想。信中写道：
The fact that I could and did carry out the crime extremely successfully is my only satisfaction. I am ashamed, upset and thoroughly disgusted at my treatment of Stephanie and the suffering I must have caused to her parents. Even now my eyes are filled with tears. I wake up during the night actually crying. With a little luck, Stephanie will get over it shortly. Myself, I do not think I ever will. The letter contained spelling and punctuation errors that matched previous correspondence from the kidnapper. The phrase, with a little luck, had also been used in one of the letters sent to British Rail. This indicated that the same person was indeed responsible for all
我能够并且确实极其成功地实施了这起犯罪，这是我唯一的满足感。我对自已对待斯蒂芬妮的方式以及我必定给她的父母带来的痛苦感到羞耻、难过和彻底的厌恶。直到现在我的眼中仍然满含泪水。我在夜里醒来时其实都在哭泣。运气好的话，斯蒂芬妮很快就会走出来。至于我自己，我认为我永远都不会。这封信包含的拼写和标点错误与绑架者之前的信件相吻合。“运气好的话”这个短语也曾出现在发给英国铁路公司的其中一封信中。这表明同一个人确实对这全部
three crimes and on Friday, February 7, snippets of the letter were published in the country's newspapers. Two days later, Stephanie finally left the hospital and was able to return home. A number of reporters had set up camp in the field's opposite her house to cover her homecoming. She agreed to pose for the cameras with her parents and two pet cats and was met at the front door by a police officer carrying a bouquet of flowers. Armed detectives took shifts guarding the family and escorting them everywhere they went, while police dogs and their handlers patrolled the land between the house and the nearby motorway. Media interest in the case was unrelenting and Stephanie was inundated with large financial
三起犯罪负有责任，2月7日星期五，该信件的片段被刊登在国家的各大报纸上。两天后，斯蒂芬妮终于离开医院并得以回家。许多记者在她家对面的田野里扎营，以报道她回家的情况。她同意与父母以及两只宠物猫一起在镜头前摆好姿势，并在前门遇到了手捧一束鲜花的警官。武装侦探轮流守卫这个家庭并护送他们去往任何地方，而警犬及其训导员则在房子与附近高速公路之间的土地上巡逻。媒体对这起案件的兴趣有增无减，斯蒂芬妮收到了大量
offers in exchange for an exclusive interview. Police advised her to negotiate a deal with one newspaper as this would prompt all other outlets to back off. She decided to sign a contract with the Sun newspaper as it was the paper her father read and also had the highest number of readers. Stephanie wanted to use her experience to alert women to the possible dangers they faced and suggest ways they could protect themselves. From the outset of the investigation, police had intentionally withheld significant details from the media and they eventually chose to release this information on an episode of BBC's Crime Watch. The show aired on the evening of Thursday, February 20, with 15 million viewers tuning in to watch.
以独家采访为交换的巨额经济报价。警方建议她与一家报纸谈判达成协议，因为这会促使其他所有媒体退让。她决定与《太阳报》签署合同，因为那是她父亲阅读的报纸，而且读者数量最多。斯蒂芬妮希望利用自己的经历提醒女性她们可能面临的潜在危险，并建议她们如何保护自己。从调查一开始，警方就刻意向媒体隐瞒了重大细节，他们最终选择在英国广播公司（BBC）的《罪案观察》节目的一集中发布这些信息。该节目于2月20日星期四晚上播出，有1500万观众收看。
For the first time, it was publicly revealed that the kidnapper drove a red Austin metro, that he appeared to have a connection with British Railways and that Stephanie had been held hostage in a workshop environment. The recorded phone call between the kidnapper and Kevin Watts was also played, prompting 1,000 phone calls to police and to the Crime Watch headquarters. 48-year-old Susan Oak had been out when the show aired, but she had taped it so she could watch it later on. The case had caught Susan's attention as the sketch of the suspect resembled her ex-husband, Michael Samms, who also drove a red car similar to the one witnessed near the location where Julie Dart's body was found. Furthermore, the suspect had reportedly
公众首次得知，绑架者开着一辆红色的奥斯汀·梅特罗轿车，他似乎与英国铁路公司有某种联系，而且斯蒂芬妮一直被关押在一个作坊环境中。绑架者和凯文·沃茨之间录下的通话录音也被播放了，这促使1000名观众打电话给警方和《罪案观察》总部。48岁的苏珊·奥克在节目播出时外出了，但她录了下来以便稍后观看。这起案件引起了苏珊的注意，因为嫌疑人的素描长得像她的前夫迈克尔·萨姆斯，而且他也开着一辆红车，类似于在发现朱莉·达特尸体地点附近看到的那辆车。此外，据报道嫌疑人
worn a railway badge on his coat and Michael loved trains. However, Michael had one leg amputated 13 years earlier and the suspect wasn't said to have a limp, so Susan deemed it unlikely that her ex could be responsible. She primarily wanted to see the Crime Watch episode to lay her suspicions to rest. At 11pm on the night the episode aired, Susan played the tape. Upon hearing the voice of the kidnapper, she leapt out of her chair and shouted, It's him. It's Mike. Michael Benerman Samms was born on August 11, 1941, in the west Yorkshire town of Keithley. He had a conventional middle-class upbringing and was a bright child who did well at school, although struggled with spelling and grammar. At the age of 20, Samms joined the merchant navy,
在他的外套上佩戴了一个铁路徽章，而迈克尔非常喜欢火车。然而，迈克尔在13年前被截去了一条腿，而嫌疑人并没有被说成有跛足，所以苏珊认为她的前夫不太可能是罪魁祸首。她看《罪案观察》这集节目主要是为了让心中的怀疑彻底平息。节目播出的当晚11点，苏珊播放了录像带。一听到绑架者的声音，她便从椅子上跳起来大喊：“是他。是迈克。”迈克尔·贝内曼·萨姆斯于1941年8月11日出生于西约克郡基斯利镇。他有着传统的中产阶级家庭背景，是一个聪明的孩子，在学校表现很好，尽管在拼写和语法方面有些吃力。20岁时，萨姆斯加入了商船队，
but returned to his hometown a year later and trained to work as a lift engineer. He met his first wife Susan when he was installing lifts at her workplace. The young couple married on July 18, 1964 and went on to have two sons. By 1970, Samms had started his own business servicing central heating boilers and was often so busy that he rarely saw his wife and children. He dedicated any spare time he had to train spotting, a term used to describe the hobby of watching trains. Samms was fascinated by rail transport. He collected train memorabilia and displayed a model railway in a spare room. In 1973, Samms suddenly became ill and was rushed to hospital.
但一年后回到家乡，并接受了电梯工程师的工作培训。他在她的工作场所安装电梯时遇到了他的第一任妻子苏珊。这对年轻夫妇于1964年7月18日结婚，随后育有两个儿子。到1970年，萨姆斯开始了自己的中央供暖锅炉维修业务，而且经常忙得很少见到妻子和孩子。他将自己所有的空闲时间都奉献给了观火车，这是用来描述观看火车这一爱好的术语。萨姆斯对铁路运输着迷。他收集铁路纪念品，并在一个空房间里展示了一个铁路模型。1973年，萨姆斯突然生病并被紧急送往医院。
Doctors suspected he had meningitis, an inflammation of the membranes around the brain and spinal cord, but tests were inconclusive. Samms managed to make a recovery, but thereafter he was prone to mood swings and violent outbursts. He and Susan argued frequently, with Samms often becoming physically and sexually aggressive. He started raping his wife and subjected her to humiliating sexual abuse. In 1976, Susan left Samms, taking the couple's two sons with her. Samms begged her to take him back while also threatening, if I can't have you, nobody else will. On one occasion, one of Samms employees told Susan that Samms had offered him money to kill her.
医生怀疑他患了脑膜炎，即大脑和脊髓周围脑膜的炎症，但检查结果却不确定。萨姆斯设法康复了，但此后他很容易情绪波动并有暴力爆发倾向。他和苏珊经常争吵，萨姆斯经常变得具有身体和性侵略性。他开始强奸他的妻子，并对她施以羞辱性的性虐待。1976年，苏珊离开萨姆斯，带走了这对夫妇的两个儿子。萨姆斯恳求她收回他，同时还威胁道：“如果我得不到你，别人也别想得到。”有一次，萨姆斯的的一名员工告诉苏珊，萨姆斯曾给钱让他杀了她。
Samms had also bragged to the employee that he knew how to carry out the perfect kidnapping. Samms and Susan divorced in 1977, and that same year, Samms stole a car, resulting in his first recorded criminal offense and nine months in prison. While serving his sentence, Samms began experiencing significant pain in his right knee. He was diagnosed with cancer, and to prevent the disease from spreading, his leg was amputated above the knee. Samms was released after serving six months. Three weeks later, he married a woman named DeJane, whom he'd met through a Lonely Hearts personal's ad. However,
萨姆斯还向该员工吹嘘说，他知道如何实施完美的绑架。萨姆斯和苏珊于1977年离婚，同年，萨姆斯偷了一辆汽车，导致他有了第一起有记录的刑事犯罪并入狱九个月。在服刑期间，萨姆斯开始感到右膝剧烈疼痛。他被诊断出患有癌症，为了防止病情扩散，他的腿在膝盖以上被截肢。萨姆斯服刑六个月后获释。三周后，他与一位名叫德简的女性结婚，两人通过“寂寞心灵”个人广告相识。然而，
Jane soon became unhappy in the relationship and ended the marriage in 1981. The next year, Samms began work as a power tool repairman for Black and Decker in Birmingham. He met his third wife, Tina, after she placed a personal ad in a local newspaper, and he soon opened his own tool repair shop in the town of Peterborough, Cambridgeshire. Samms often criticised Tina and pestered her for sex, which caused their marriage to deteriorate within a few years. He once threatened to go to Leeds to find a sex worker, saying he knew which areas they frequented. Despite being unhappy, the couple stayed together and eventually moved to the village of Sutton
简很快对这段关系感到不满，并在1981年结束了这段婚姻。第二年，萨姆斯开始在伯明翰的百得公司担任电动工具修理工。他在当地一家报纸上刊登征友广告后遇到了他的第三任妻子蒂娜，不久之后他在剑桥郡彼得伯勒镇开设了自己的工具修理店。萨姆斯经常批评蒂娜并纠缠她要求发生性关系，这导致他们的婚姻在几年内恶化。他曾威胁说要去利兹找一个性工作者，并称他知道她们常去哪些地方。尽管很不快乐，这对夫妇还是在一起了，并最终搬到了萨顿
on Trent, which was approximately halfway between Leeds and Birmingham. Samms started his own business repairing power tools and had a shop in the nearby town of Newick. Susan Oak had little to do with her ex-husband, though her son still saw him occasionally. In mid-February 1992, Samms' father died and Susan attended his funeral, where she saw Samms for the first time in four years. He appeared strange and evasive, refusing to make eye contact, or give Susan a lift to the cemetery in his red Austin metro. His voice and peculiar behaviour were still clear in Susan's mind several days later when she watched the Crime Watch episode, and she had no doubt that he was responsible for the crimes.
昂特村，该村大约位于利兹和伯明翰的中点。萨姆斯开始了自己的电动工具维修业务，并在附近的纽瓦克镇拥有了一家店铺。苏珊·奥克与她的前夫几乎没有什么联系，尽管她的儿子偶尔还会见到他。1992年2月中旬，萨姆斯的父亲去世了，苏珊出席了他的葬礼，在那里她四年里第一次见到了萨姆斯。他显得很奇怪而且闪烁其词，拒绝进行目光接触，或者用他的红色奥斯汀·梅特罗车顺便载苏珊去墓地。几天后，当苏珊观看《罪案观察》节目时，他的声音和古怪的行为仍然清晰地印在她的脑海中，她毫不怀疑他对这些罪行负有责任。
She immediately called the Crime Watch hotline, but it was busy, so she reported her suspicions to the Julie Dutt incident room in Leeds instead. One of her sons also called Crime Watch to back his mother's report. Among the hundreds of calls that were coming through, the West Yorkshire police quickly prioritised Susan's information, and two officers were dispatched to her home. By 2am, Michael Samms had officially been placed on the suspect list, along with four other individuals. At 10.40am on Friday, February 21, four high-ranking officers were dispatched to Samms' residence in Sutton on Trent. His wife, Tina, answered the door and explained that her husband was at work. One of the detectives noticed an abundance of railway paraphernalia hanging on
她立即拨打了《罪案观察》的热线电话，但电话占线，于是她改向利兹的朱莉·达特案专案组报告了她的怀疑。她的一个儿子也打电话给《罪案观察》以支持他母亲的举报。在源源不断打进来的数百个电话中，西约克郡警方迅速将苏珊提供的信息列为首要任务，并派了两名警官前往她的住所。到凌晨2点，迈克尔·萨姆斯与另外四个人一起被正式列入嫌疑人名单。2月21日星期五上午10点40分，四名高级警官被派往萨姆斯位于萨顿昂特的住所。他的妻子蒂娜开门并解释说她的丈夫去上班了。其中一名侦探注意到挂在
the walls of the house, including photographs of trains and salvaged engine name plates. There was also a moped, a German shepherd, and a fish tank. These details were significant as a fish food container had been used to construct the fake incendiary device found in the Julie Dutt case. Stephanie had also been shown a German shepherd puppy while in captivity, and police believed the kidnapper may have driven a motorbike of some kind when picking up the ransom money. The officers told Tina they would return at 5pm, but then rushed to Samms' shop eight miles away in Newark, hoping that Tina wouldn't alert him to their visit. They pulled up at the address, where a hand stenciled sign read, T&M Tools. Samms' red Austin Metro was parked outside,
房屋墙壁上有大量的铁路纪念品，包括火车的照片和回收的发动机铭牌。那里还有一辆轻便摩托车、一只德国牧羊犬和一个鱼缸。这些细节意义重大，因为在朱莉·达特案中发现的假燃烧装置是用一个鱼食容器制作的。斯蒂芬妮在被囚禁期间也曾被展示过一只德国牧羊犬幼犬，警方认为绑架者在收取赎金时可能驾驶了某种摩托车。警官们告诉蒂娜他们将在下午5点返回，但随后赶往八英里外位于纽瓦克的萨姆斯的店铺，希望蒂娜不会向他通风报信。他们把车停在该地址前，那里有一个手绘ステンシル（stencil）招牌，上面写着“T&M工具”。萨姆斯的红色奥斯汀·梅特罗停在外面，
and a railway line ran nearby, which could account for the trains that Stephanie heard during her time in captivity. Inside, tools were hanging on the wall, and a cash register sat on the counter, but nobody was there. A number of other features aligned with Stephanie's recollections. There was an old rotary-style telephone, a microwave, a bell above the door, and a radio playing that was tuned to BBC Radio 2. One of the officers called out, and Samms emerged from behind a curtain, stating, I've been expecting you. What is it you want? The officers explained that he was under arrest for suspicion of abduction and murder relating
附近有一条铁路线，这可以解释斯蒂芬妮在被囚禁期间听到的火车声音。里面，工具挂在墙上，柜台上放着一个收银机，但里面空无一人。许多其他特征与斯蒂芬妮的回忆相吻合。这里有一部旧式转盘电话、一个微波炉、门上方的一个铃铛，以及一台正在播放且调到BBC广播二台的收音机。其中一名警官喊了一声，萨姆斯从一块窗帘后面走了出来，说道：“我一直在等你们。你们想要什么？”警官们解释说他因涉嫌与
to Julie Dart and Stephanie Slater. Samms retorted, You've got the wrong man. You are making a big mistake. He was taken to the nearest police station and held for questioning. A young constable tasked with guarding Samms asked what he was in for. Samms replied, Suspicion of murder and abduction. Didn't you watch Crime Watch last night? The constable said that he hadn't, and asked whether Samms was referring to the Stephanie Slater case. Samms responded, Yes, the evidence is in the workshop. I didn't do the murder. I don't know how they've linked the two. Startled, the constable asked Samms if he was responsible for Stephanie's abduction. He replied, Yeah, but I didn't do the other one.
朱莉·达特和斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特有关的绑架和谋杀而遭到逮捕。萨姆斯反驳道：“你们抓错人了。你们犯了一个大错误。”他被带到最近的警察局并被拘留盘问。一名负责看守萨姆斯的年轻警员问他因为什么事被抓。萨姆斯回答说：“涉嫌谋杀和绑架。你们昨晚没看《罪案观察》吗？”这名警员说他没看，并问萨姆斯指的是不是斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特案。萨姆斯回答说：“是的，证据就在作坊里。谋杀不是我干的。我不知道他们是怎么把这两起案子联系起来的。”大吃一惊的警员问萨姆斯他是否对斯蒂芬妮的绑架负责。他回答说：“是的，但我没干另一桩。”
Samms was taken to the station's sergeant to repeat his admission. He stated, I've done the kidnapping. I've not done the murder. I promised Stephanie that she'd go home. And she did. Following this confession, Samms was stripped, searched and given new clothes with his own sent off for forensic testing. As he was moved throughout the station, he continued to provide further details to the young constable whenever the two were left alone. Samms explained that he was annoyed when the real estate agency sent a woman to the property at 153 Turnbury Road, as he would have become less emotionally attached to a male hostage. He also boasted about successfully hiding the fact that he had a prosthetic leg from Stephanie,
萨姆斯被带到警局警长面前重复了他的供词。他陈述道：“绑架是我干的。谋杀不是我干的。我答应过斯蒂芬妮她会回家。她也确实回去了。”在此次供认之后，萨姆斯被脱光衣服搜身并换上了新衣服，他自己的衣服则被送去进行法医检测。当他在警局各处被转移时，每当两人单独相处，他总是会向年轻警员提供更多细节。萨姆斯解释说，当房地产公司在特恩伯里路153号派了一个女性来看房时，他感到很恼火，因为他对男性人质的情感依恋会少一些。他还吹嘘自己成功地向斯蒂芬妮隐瞒了自己有一条假肢的事实，
and added that he only carried out the kidnapping because he was bored and lonely. Samms' first formal interview commenced later that afternoon. He repeated his confession and explained that he'd buried most of the ransom money after dropping Stephanie home. He said that he only asked for 175,000 pounds because it seemed like a realistic amount that would be manageable to carry. By the time the interview ended, news had broken about the arrest. Samms was transferred to a police station in Birmingham, where angry crowds were waiting out the front to hurl abuse as he was rushed inside. Meanwhile, forensic investigators had been inspecting Samms' workshop for evidence and found 19,000 pounds in cash. They discovered that the
并补充说他实施绑架纯粹是因为感到无聊和孤独。萨姆斯的第一次正式审讯于那天下午晚些时候开始。他重复了自己的供词，并解释说他在把斯蒂芬妮送回家后埋掉了大部分赎金。他说他只索要175,000英镑，是因为这看起来是一个切合实际且便于携带的金额。审讯结束时，关于逮捕的消息已经传开。萨姆斯被转移到伯明翰的一家警察局，愤怒的人群在门外等待着，当他被匆忙带进去时，对他进行辱骂。与此同时，法医调查人员一直在检查萨姆斯的作坊以寻找证据，并找到了19,000英镑现金。他们发现，
chamber he had kept Stephanie in was a custom-built timber box that had been placed inside a sideways plastic wheelie bin. A number of human hairs matching Stephanie's were found, while other dyed strands of hair looked like they could belong to Julie Dart. A diluted blood stain was found on an old curtain which someone appeared to have attempted to wash away with water. There wasn't enough blood to obtain a DNA profile, but the blood type was identified as the same as Julie's. Brown nylon fibers on the workshop floor also matched those found on the sheets used to wrap Julie's body. An inspection of Samms' computer revealed a disturbing word document written in the style of a police statement. It explained that he had picked up a young sex worker named
关押斯蒂芬妮的房间是一个定制的木制箱子，被放在一个横放的塑料带轮垃圾桶里。发现了许多与斯蒂芬妮相匹配的人类头发，而其他染过的头发看起来可能属于朱莉·达特。在一块旧窗帘上发现了一个稀释的血迹，有人似乎曾试图用水将其洗掉。血迹不足以提取DNA图谱，但血型被鉴定为与朱莉的血型相同。作坊地板上的棕色尼龙纤维也与用来包裹朱莉尸体的床单上发现的纤维相匹配。对萨姆斯的计算机进行检查后发现了一份令人不安的Word文档，其风格类似于警方笔录。其中解释说，他在利兹接了一名年轻的性工作者，名叫
Julie from Leeds, who said she worked at the Leeds General Infirmary. She mentioned having a boyfriend whose name began with D.O., but she stopped herself before revealing his whole name. The two had sex, during which Samms noticed that Julie had a number of bruises on her body. Afterwards, she wrote the name Julie D. on a business card and told him, I will be around here some evenings. I get dropped off about 10.45 and collected around 11.30. Samms claimed he'd returned to the area a few days later, but didn't see Julie again. Investigators also searched the tool repair shop in Cambridgeshire that Samms had run several years earlier. There, they found a number of unusual bricks that matched the one found during the Julie
朱莉，她说自己在利兹总医院工作。她提到自己有一个男朋友，名字以D.O.开头，但在说出全名之前她打住了。两人发生了性关系，在此期间萨姆斯注意到朱莉身上有许多瘀伤。之后，她在名片上写下了“朱莉·D.”这个名字并告诉他：“我有些晚上会在这附近。我大概10点45分左右下车，11点30分左右被接走。”萨姆斯声称他几天后回到了该地区，但没有再见到朱莉。调查人员还搜查了萨姆斯几年前在剑桥郡经营的工具修理店。在那里，他们找到了许多不同寻常的砖块，与朱莉·达特
Dart investigation. That brick had been painted white and had an envelope attached with instructions, and a forensic examination revealed that it had been made from blue-colored clay. The bricks found at Samms' former shop were of the same size and color. Samms' wife Tina told investigators that she and her husband had watched the latest episode of Crime Watch together, and that Samms had commented that the suspect sketch looked like him 10 years prior. Tina had agreed and joked, You've got a metro and you live near a railway line. It's a good job you've got a tin leg. When Samms' mother was questioned, she said that he and Tina had visited her on July 21, 1991.
调查中发现的那块砖相吻合。那块砖被刷成了白色，并附有一个带有指示的信封，法医检验显示它是用蓝色的粘土制成的。在萨姆斯前店铺找到的砖块大小和颜色都一样。萨姆斯的妻子蒂娜告诉调查人员，她和丈夫一起观看了最新一集的《罪案观察》，萨姆斯曾评论说嫌疑人的素描看起来像10岁前的他。蒂娜表示赞同并开玩笑说：“你有一辆梅特罗，而且你住在铁路线附近。你长了一条锡腿，这可真走运。”当萨姆斯的母亲接受盘问时，她说他和蒂娜曾在1991年7月21日去看望过她。
This matched the date that Julie Dart killer had posted a letter to the police from Leeds Railway Station. Tina confirmed that she and her husband had stopped at the station during their trip, while other journeys Samms had made also aligned with dates that other ransom letters had been sent. Samms' ex-wife Susan Oak was shown some of these letters, and confirmed that the spelling and grammatical errors matched those she'd seen before in Samms' writing. On Saturday, February 22, the police continued to formally interview Samms about Stephanie's kidnapping. When talking about Stephanie, he often started crying, saying that he couldn't bring himself to hurt her. Samms adamantly denied having anything to do with the Julie
这与朱莉·达特凶手从利兹火车站寄出一封信给警察的日期相吻合。蒂娜证实她和丈夫在旅行途中曾在该车站停留，而萨姆斯进行的其它行程也与寄出其他赎金信的日期相吻合。萨姆斯的前妻苏珊·奥克被出示了其中一些信件，并证实其中的拼写和语法错误与她以前在萨姆斯的书写中看到的相吻合。2月22日星期六，警方继续就斯蒂芬妮的绑架案对萨姆斯进行正式审讯。在谈到斯蒂芬妮时，他经常开始哭泣，说自己狠不下心去伤害她。萨姆斯坚决否认自己与朱莉·达特
Dart's murder, or being familiar with the Chapel Town's red light district, insisting he was incapable of hurting a woman. When the police pointed out that Julie's body was disposed of in a wheelie bin, and that he had made a similar threat to Stephanie, Samms dismissed this as a coincidence. The day's interrogation concluded, and police applied for a 36-hour extension on Samms' detention so they could continue questioning him about Julie. The following morning, Samms provided investigators with a lengthy written statement in which he claimed to have an accomplice in Stephanie's kidnapping. He said he paid the accomplice £20,000 to drive him to the Glossoper Raleway Station, which was the first site that Stephanie's manager Kevin Watts was
的谋杀案有任何关系，也否认熟悉查普尔敦的红灯区，坚称自己没有能力伤害女性。当警方指出朱莉的尸体是被处理在一个带轮垃圾桶里，并且他对斯蒂芬妮做出过类似的威胁时，萨姆斯对此不以为然，称这只是个巧合。当天的审讯结束了，警方申请将萨姆斯的拘留时间延长36小时，以便他们能够继续就朱莉一案对他进行讯问。第二天早上，萨姆斯向调查人员提供了一份冗长的书面陈述，其中他声称在斯蒂芬妮的绑架案中有一名同谋。他说他付给这名同谋20,000英镑，开车送他去格洛索普火车站，那是斯蒂芬妮的经理凯文·沃茨被指引去的第一个地点，
directed to, leaving Samms with a moped and other equipment. After Samms had successfully obtained the ransom money, the accomplice picked him up and insisted that Stephanie be killed. Samms refused, and a violent argument broke out between the two men. The accomplice only relented when Samms offered to give him a majority of the money. Samms claimed that it was his accomplice who was responsible for blackmailing British Rail and for murdering Julie Dart. The accomplice had allegedly kept Julie tied to a bed in a chalet on the east coast of England and beat her with a hammer when she tried to escape from his sexual abuse. Samms also claimed that his accomplice had a key to Samms' workshop and had used his computer on
只留下萨姆斯和一辆轻便摩托车及其他设备。在萨姆斯成功获得赎金后，同谋接上了他并坚持要求杀死斯蒂芬妮。萨姆斯拒绝了，两人之间爆发了激烈的争吵。直到萨姆斯提出把大部分钱分给他，同谋才做出妥协。萨姆斯声称，正是他的同谋负责勒索英国铁路公司并谋杀朱莉·达特。据称，同谋将朱莉绑在英格兰东海岸一间小木屋的床上，并在她试图挣脱性虐待时用锤子殴打她。萨姆斯还声称他的同谋有萨姆斯作坊的钥匙，并曾多次使用他的计算机。
multiple occasions. Samms refused to name this individual out of fear he might harm Stephanie in retaliation. Investigators didn't believe that another individual was involved. Instead, they were convinced this was Samms' way of explaining the evidence that linked him to the other two cases. They obtained a writing sample from Samms and had an expert compare it to the handwritten letters from Julie Dart's case. The sample featured a number of notable similarities to the letters, including 14 identical spelling errors. The expert concluded that Samms was the author of the letters. On Monday, February 24, Michael Samms was formally charged with the kidnapping of Stephanie Slater, as well as unlawfully holding her prisoner and demanding
萨姆斯拒绝说出这个人的名字，因为担心他会进行报复而伤害斯蒂芬妮。调查人员不相信有另一个人参与。相反，他们确信这是萨姆斯用来解释将他与另外两起案件联系起来的证据的一种方式。他们从萨姆斯那里获取了笔迹样本，并让专家将其与朱莉·达特案中的手写信件进行比对。该样本具有与信件惊人的许多相似之处，包括14处完全相同的拼写错误。专家得出结论，萨姆斯就是这些信件的作者。2月24日星期星期一，迈克尔·萨姆斯被正式指控绑架斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特，以及非法将她作为人质扣押并以威胁方式向她的雇主索要
175,000 pounds from her employer with menaces. Two days later, he was also charged with the murder of Julie Dart and with demanding 140,000 pounds with menaces from West Yorkshire Police. Samms was remanded in custody pending trial, during which he continued to undergo interviews with the police. During one interview, he suddenly confessed to another failed kidnapping attempt. Samms admitted that one week before Julie's disappearance, he made an appointment to view a house with Nottingham real estate agent, 42-year-old Carol Jones. He went armed with a knife and rope, intending to abduct her, but his plans were foiled when a builder working on the house next door started chatting to him while he waited for Carol to arrive. Samms ended up leaving before
175,000英镑。两天后，他还被指控谋杀朱莉·达特，并以威胁方式向西约克郡警方勒索140,000英镑。萨姆斯被还押候审，在此期间他继续接受警方审讯。在一次审讯中，他突然供认了另一起未遂绑架案。萨姆斯承认，在朱莉失踪前一周，他预约与诺丁汉房地产经纪人、42岁的卡罗尔·琼斯一起看房。他带着一把刀和绳子去，企图绑架她，但当他在等卡罗尔到达时，隔壁房子施工的一名建筑工人开始跟他闲聊，他的计划落空了。萨姆斯最终在卡罗尔到达之前离开了。
Carol got there. Investigators spoke with Carol Jones, who remembered that her client was a no show that day. One of her colleagues, Karen Langdon, recalled going to meet a client at that same Nottingham property. Upon her arrival, she had been approached by a man carrying a clipboard who was wearing glasses similar to Michael Samms. He walked away at the last moment, and Karen noticed he walked with a slight limp. Both Carol and Karen were shocked to learn they had escaped a brush with a kidnapper. Karen was particularly shaken, as she had resigned from her job after Stephanie Slater's abduction out of fear of the risks involved. Michael Samms eventually admitted to writing the ransom letters, but claimed his accomplice had
调查人员与卡罗尔·琼斯进行了交谈，她记得她的客户那天没有出现。她的同事凯伦·朗登回忆说，她曾去诺丁汉的那处房产见一位客户。她一到达，就有一个拿着写字板、戴着类似于迈克尔·萨姆斯的眼镜的男子向她走来。他在最后一刻走开了，凯伦注意到他走路有点跛。卡罗尔和凯伦得知自己躲过了一场与绑架者的接触后都感到震惊。凯伦尤其受到震动，因为她在斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特被绑架后，出于对所涉风险的恐惧而从工作中辞职了。迈克尔·萨姆斯最终承认写了赎金信，但声称他的同谋
forced him to do so. As he maintained that this individual had the majority of the ransom money, finding the cash became a priority for investigators, as it would disprove Samms' claims about a second perpetrator once and for all. Two witnesses had reported that in July of 1991, they saw a man with a walking stick on a disused railway track less than one mile from where Julie's body was found. Samms denied ever visiting the area, except for one occasion, when he visited a popular trainspotting destination named Stoke Summit. Police then spoke with a retired colonel from the special air service, who had specialized in finding arms caches. He advised that the money
强迫他这么做。由于他坚称此人拥有大部分赎金，找到这笔现金成了调查人员的首要任务，因为这将一劳永逸地反驳萨姆斯关于第二个作案者的说法。两名目击者报告说，在1991年7月，他们看到一个拿着手杖的男子在距离发现朱莉尸体不到一英里的一条废弃铁路上。萨姆斯否认去过该地区，只有一个例外，那就是他曾去过一个受欢迎的观火车目的地，名叫斯托克峰顶。随后，警方与一名特种空勤团的退役上校进行了交谈，该上校专长于寻找武器藏匿点。他建议说，这笔钱
would likely be buried in a remote location that was close to public access. Based on this advice and the witness sighting, police honed in on the Stoke Summit railway embankment, located 1.7 miles from where Julie's body had been dumped. On December 2, 1992, just over 10 months after Stephanie's kidnapping, they used ground probing radar to dig in the area. Eight inches below the surface, they found a black tray wrapped in polythene topped with a newspaper dated February 6, 1992. Inside, there were stacks of banknotes. When Samms heard about the discovery, he told police the parcel was one of two he'd prepared,
可能会被埋在一个靠近公众通道的偏远地点。根据这一建议和目击者的目击情况，警方锁定了距离朱莉尸体被丢弃处1.7英里的斯托克峰顶铁路路基。1992年12月2日，就在斯蒂芬妮被绑架10个月后，他们使用探地雷达在该地区进行挖掘。在地下八英寸深处，他们发现了一个用塑料布包裹的黑色托盘，上面压着一份日期为1992年2月6日的报纸。里面是一叠叠的钞票。当萨姆斯听到这一发现时，他告诉警方这个包裹是他准备的两个包裹之一，
but claimed that it must have been buried by his accomplice. Two days later, buried 16 feet away from the first, police recovered the second parcel of money. All up, they recovered all of the ransom money, less 12,500 pounds, which was never found. Michael Samms' trial commenced at the Nottingham Crown Court on June 9, 1993. He pleaded guilty to the charges relating to Stephanie Slater, but not guilty to Julie's abduction and murder, and not guilty to the attempted extortion of British Rail. Over two and a half days, the prosecutor delivered a dramatic opening speech, detailing what he dubbed Michael Samms' campaign of crime.
但他声称这一定是被他的同谋埋下的。两天后，在距离第一个包裹16英尺远的地方，警方挖出了第二个装钱的包裹。总共找回了除了12,500英镑（这笔钱一直未找到）之外的所有赎金。迈克尔·萨姆斯的审判于1993年6月9日在诺丁汉刑事法院开庭。他对与斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特相关的指控表示认罪，但对朱莉的绑架和谋杀表示不认罪，对企图敲诈勒索英国铁路公司表示不认罪。在两年半的时间里，检察官发表了戏剧性的开场陈词，详细描述了他所谓迈克尔·萨姆斯的犯罪运动。
Julie Dart was known to be terrified of confined spaces, and was described as someone who would have fought back against an attacker. The prosecution's theory was that Julie had likely attempted to escape from the box Samms held her in, and Samms had then killed her out of fear that she had seen too much. The prosecution believed that Stephanie had survived because she had played along with Samms' demands. When Stephanie took the stand to deliver her testimony, she kept her eyes to the ground, while Samms sobbed in the background. The defense called Michael Samms as their first witness. He maintained that his accomplice had murdered Julie Dart and had forced Samms to write the ransom letters. As for Stephanie's
众所周知，朱莉·达特非常害怕狭小空间，被描述为一个会反抗袭击者的人。检方的理论是，朱莉很可能曾试图从萨姆斯关押她的箱子里逃跑，而萨姆斯随后出于担心她看到太多而杀死了她。检方认为斯蒂芬妮之所以能幸存，是因为她顺从了萨姆斯的要求。当斯蒂芬妮走上证人席作证时，她一直把目光盯在地上，而萨姆斯则在后台抽泣。辩方传唤迈克尔·萨姆斯作为他们的第一位证人。他坚称他的同谋谋杀了朱莉·达特，并强迫萨姆斯写了赎金信。至于斯蒂芬妮的
kidnapping, he claimed he was financially motivated to commit the crime because he wanted to buy a nice house for his wife in an attempt to mend their relationship. During cross-examination, Samms refused to name Julie's killer, saying he would only do so at the conclusion of the trial after proving himself innocent. The prosecutor accused Samms of lying, stating, quote, you cannot bring yourself to admit that you killed Julie Dart, and like a little child, you have invented this friend. The trial ran for four weeks, and on July 8, the jury retired to consider their verdict. They deliberated for three and a half hours before declaring Michael Samms guilty of all charges,
绑架案，他声称自己犯罪的动机是经济上的，因为他想为妻子买一套好房子，以此来修复他们的关系。在盘问过程中，萨姆斯拒绝说出朱莉的凶手是谁，并表示他只有在审判结束、证明自己无罪后才会这样做。检察官指控萨姆斯撒谎，并说：“引述一下，你无法让自己承认你杀害朱莉·达特，就像一个小孩子一样，你捏造了这个朋友。”审判持续了四个星期，7月8日，陪审团退席商议裁决。他们商议了三个半小时，随后宣告迈克尔·萨姆斯所有指控全部成立，
including Julie's murder and the British Rail extortion attempt. Those seated in the public gallery applauded and cheered, while Stephanie Slater cried and mouthed, thank you to the jury. Julie's mother, Lynn Dart, cried out, you bastard, before bursting into tears. Samms showed no emotion as the judge addressed him directly, saying, quote, you are an extremely dangerous and evil man. The jury has convicted you of the murder of Julie Dart. That was murder in cold blood. A kidnap gone wrong because she saw more than she should. Undeterred by the horror of what you had done, you tried to turn her death to your advantage. When Stephanie Slater was kidnapped, I have not the slightest doubt that she was in desperate
包括谋杀朱莉和企图勒索英国铁路公司。旁听席上的人们鼓掌欢呼，而斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特则哭泣着对陪审团口型说了“谢谢”。朱莉的母亲琳恩·达特大喊“你这个混蛋”，随后痛哭失声。当法官直接向萨姆斯说话时，萨姆斯没有表现出任何情绪，法官说：“引述一下，你是一个极其危险和邪恶的人。陪审团已经裁定你谋杀朱莉·达特罪名成立。那是冷血谋杀。一场出了差错的绑架，因为她看到了她不该看的东西。没有被你所做事情的恐怖所吓退，你试图把她的死转化为对你有利的条件。当斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特被绑架时，我毫不怀疑她正处于绝望
and mortal danger. The ordeal that you inflicted on her is something that the rest of us can only imagine. Her survival, in my judgment, is entirely due to her own remarkable moral courage. For his crimes against Julie and Stephanie, the judge sentenced Samms to four life terms. He also received concurrent 10-year sentences for each of the Blackmail attempts and the attempted extortion of British Rail. When Stephanie was later asked how she felt, she remarked, well, he shouldn't have done it, should he, if he was going to cry like that after what he has done. I can show him tears. I can show him lots of tears, stronger, upsetting, natural tears. Outside court, Lynn Dart told reporters, quote, I know we will never have Julie back.
和致命的危险之中。你施加在她身上的磨难是我们其他人只能想象的。在我看来，她的生存完全归功于她自己非凡的道德勇气。”由于他对朱莉和斯蒂芬妮犯下的罪行，法官判处萨姆斯四个终身监禁。他还因每一次勒索未遂和企图勒索英国铁路公司的罪名被判处合并执行的10年有期徒刑。当后来问及斯蒂芬妮有何感受时，她评论道：“好吧，他不该那么做的，不是吗，如果他在做了那种事之后还要哭得像那样的话。我可以给他看眼泪。我可以给他看很多眼泪，更强烈、更让人心碎、自然的眼泪。”在法庭外，琳恩·达特告诉记者：“引述一下，我知道我们永远无法找回朱莉了。
I also know that justice has been done at last, and that beast Samms, and that's what he is, has got what he justly deserves. Samms was sent to serve his sentence at Full Sutton Prison in Yorkshire. Four days after his conviction, he requested to speak with West Yorkshire Detective Superintendent Bob Taylor, who had been in charge of the Julie Dart inquiry. Samms told the detective that he had seen a photo of Julie Dart's headstone on television and noticed that it didn't have an exact date for her death. Consequently, he had decided to come clean as he wanted Julie's mother to know when her daughter had died. Samms confessed that he had lured Julie into his car at 11.30
我也知道正义终于得到了伸张，那个野兽萨姆斯——他就是个野兽——得到了他罪有应得的下场。”萨姆斯被送往约克郡的全萨顿监狱服刑。在他被定罪四天后，他要求与负责朱莉·达特调查的西约克郡侦探总督察鲍勃·泰勒交谈。萨姆斯告诉这位侦探，他在电视上看到了朱莉·达特墓碑的照片，发现上面没有她去世的具体日期。因此，他决定坦白，因为他想让朱莉的母亲知道她的女儿是什么时候死的。萨姆斯供认，他在1991年7月9日星期二晚上11点30分
on Tuesday, July 9, 1991, under the guise of hiring her for sex work. When she leaned forward in the passenger seat to remove her shoes, he placed a noose around her neck and drove her to his workshop. There, he stripped her clothes, tied her to a chair, and forced her to ride a ransom letter to her boyfriend. Samms then confined Julie in the box inside the wheelie bin, like he did with Stephanie. The next day, Julie managed to smash her way out, but Samms had set up a trigger mechanism that sent him a phone call to alert him to any escape attempts. Shortly before 6pm, the trigger went off and Samms raced over to the workshop.
以招募她从事性工作为幌子，将朱莉引诱进他的车里。当她身体前倾在副驾驶座位上脱鞋时，他将一根绞索套在她的脖子上，并把她带到了他的作坊。在那里，他剥光她的衣服，把她绑在椅子上，并强迫她给她的男朋友写一封赎金信。然后，萨姆斯把朱莉关在带轮垃圾桶内的箱子里，就像他对斯蒂芬妮做的那样。第二天，朱莉设法砸开箱子逃了出来，但萨姆斯设置了一个触发机制，会在有任何逃跑企图时向他发送电话警报。傍晚6点前不久，触发器响了，萨姆斯冲向作坊。
Using a hammer, he knocked Julie unconscious before strangling her to death. Although she was no longer alive, Samms proceeded with his extortion attempt by continuing to send ransom letters to the police. After Samms' confession, Detective Superintendent Taylor met with the Julie Darts family to share this new information. Lynn Dart was finally able to update her daughter's headstone with the Julie's exact date of death. She told Yorkshire Television, quote, Samms has known for two years that he did it. He knew all through the trial that he was guilty, so why does he now decide to come out and say it? He is just walked and twisted.
他用锤子将朱莉打昏，然后将其勒死。尽管朱莉已经遇害，萨姆斯仍继续勒索，不断向警方发送勒索信。在萨姆斯供认后，警司泰勒会见了朱莉·达茨的家人，告知了这一新情况。琳·达特终于得以在女儿的墓碑上更新了朱莉的准确死亡日期。她对约克郡电视台说道：萨姆斯两年前就知道是他干的。他在审判期间明明知道自己有罪，为什么现在又决定站出来承认？他这人真是既变态又扭曲。
He is twisting the knife and rubbing salt in the wound as well. It is just another game in his book. One month later, portions of a letter that Samms had written to his now estranged wife Tina were published in newspapers throughout Britain. In it, Samms revealed that he had always intended to release Stephanie and had always planned on killing Julie. Based on this information, investigators theorised that Samms had likely abducted and killed Julie as a trial run for his subsequent abduction scheme. From the moment Stephanie Slater was abducted, comparisons were made to the 1986
他这简直是在伤口上撒盐。这对他来说不过是又一场游戏。一个月后，萨姆斯写给当时分居的妻子蒂娜的一封信的部分内容被英国各地的报纸公开发表。信中，萨姆斯透露他原本就打算释放斯蒂芬妮，而杀死朱莉则在计划之中。基于这些信息，调查人员推测，萨姆斯绑架并杀害朱莉很可能是为其随后的绑架计划进行的一场预演。从斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特被绑架的那一刻起，人们就将其与1986年的案件进行了对比。
disappearance of Susie Lamplew, which was covered in episode 48 of Case File. Susie was a 25-year-old British estate agent who vanished after going to show a house to a client named Mr Kipper, and her case has never been solved. Stephanie had been well aware of Susie's disappearance, and as a real estate agent herself, she had initially started carrying a personal alarm when she was out showing houses. However, by the time of her own abduction in 1992, the memory of Susie's tragedy had faded, and Stephanie no longer carried the alarm. During her time being held hostage, Samms had assured Stephanie that he had nothing to do with Susie's disappearance, but after his arrest, the media speculated that he may be responsible.
苏茜·兰普劳失踪案，该案在“案件档案”第48集中有详细报道。苏茜是一名25岁的英国房地产经纪人，在带客户基珀先生看房后神秘失踪，至今悬而未决。斯蒂芬妮对苏茜的失踪非常清楚，作为一名房地产经纪人，她最初在带人看房时也开始随身携带个人警报器。然而，到了1992年她自己被绑架时，对苏茜悲剧的记忆已经淡去，斯蒂芬妮不再携带警报器。在被扣为人质期间，萨姆斯曾向斯蒂芬妮保证他与苏茜的失踪无关，但在他被捕后，媒体猜测他可能难辞其咎。
Police dismissed this theory, stating that Samms wasn't a likely culprit, but had likely been inspired by the case. In 1994, Samms allegedly sent a letter from prison confessing to Susie's abduction, but it was dismissed by police as a sick hoax. The following year, crime writer Christopher Berry D published a book titled, Unmasking Mr Kipper Who Really Killed Susie Lamplew, which argued that Samms was responsible for the crime. The Lamplew family were never consulted about the book and were unhappy about its publication.
警方驳斥了这一理论，称萨姆斯不像是真凶，但很可能是受到了该案的启发。1994年，萨姆斯据称从狱中写信承认自己绑架了苏茜，但被警方斥为恶作剧。次年，犯罪作家克里斯托弗·贝里·D出版了一本名为《揭秘基珀先生：究竟是谁杀害了苏茜·兰普劳》的书，论证了萨姆斯应当为该罪行负责。兰普劳的家人从未就该书咨询过意见，并对它的出版感到不满。
Susie's mother Diana publicly stated her belief that Berry D was using her daughter's disappearance to sell his book, which was far more focused on Michael Samms than on Susie. Stephanie Slater found it difficult to return to normal life after her abduction. She was unable to return to her job, struggled to socialize with friends, and to end her relationship with her boyfriend. As a result of being kept in the wooden box, she suffered from chronic back pain as well as anxiety, nightmares, and panic attacks. People recognized her everywhere she went, so she altered her appearance and temporarily changed her name in an attempt to create a new identity.
苏茜的母亲戴安娜公开表示，她认为贝里D是在利用她女儿的失踪来卖书，而这本书的重点更多在于迈克尔·萨姆斯而非苏茜。斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特在绑架案后很难回归正常生活。她无法重返工作岗位，难以与朋友社交，并结束了与男友的关系。由于被关在木箱里，她患上了慢性背痛以及焦虑症、噩梦和恐慌发作。无论走到哪里人们都能认出她，因此她改变了外貌，并临时改名，试图创造一个新的身份。
Stephanie also struggled with the fact that she had survived, while Julie Dart hadn't been so lucky. She met Julie's mother and grandparents and went with Lynn Dart to place flowers on Julie's grave. In an attempt to find closure, Stephanie decided to go back to the workshop where she'd been held hostage and agreed that television network Central Television could film the visit. Seeing the workshop unblindfolded for the first time, she was surprised by how small it was and how close it was to a main road. Though she found the experience unnerving, it didn't provide the resolution Stephanie was looking for. In need of a fresh start, in October 1993, she decided to relocate to the Isle of Wight
斯蒂芬妮还要面对一个事实：自己活了下来，而朱莉·达特却没有那么幸运。她见到了朱莉的母亲和祖父母，并和琳·达特一起去朱莉的墓前献花。为了寻求了结，斯蒂芬妮决定回到她被劫为人质的车间，并同意中央电视台拍摄这次访问。当她第一次在不被蒙住眼睛的情况下看到这个车间时，她惊讶于它是如此之小，且距离主路如此之近。尽管她觉得这段经历让人神经紧绷，但它并没有提供斯蒂芬妮所寻求的解脱。由于急需重新开始，1993年10月，她决定搬到怀特岛
with her best friend Stacy Kettner. Stephanie had spent many happy summers there as a child and described it as her own personal heaven on earth. The following year, she began working as a part-time tour guide at a historic castle. This helped to give her life focus and encouraged her to speak to strangers again. Stephanie developed a close-knit circle of friends and attributed her recovery to the support of her loved ones. Stephanie decided to write a book about her ordeal in the hopes her story might help others. Titled, Beyond Fear, My Will to Survive, the book revealed that Stephanie had in fact been raped by Michael Samms during her first night as a hostage.
和她最好的朋友斯黛西·凯特纳一起。斯蒂芬妮童年时在那里度过了许多快乐的夏天，并将其描述为她人间的天堂。第二年，她在历史悠久的城堡里开始做兼职导游。这帮她找到了生活的重心，并鼓励她重新与陌生人交流。斯蒂芬妮建立了一个紧密的朋友圈，并将自己的康复归功于挚爱之人的支持。斯蒂芬妮决定写一本关于自己苦难经历的书，希望她的故事能帮助他人。这本书名为《超越恐惧，我的求生意志》，书中透露斯蒂芬妮在作为人质的第一晚实际上遭到了迈克尔·萨姆斯的强奸。
She had originally withheld this information as she was terrified that the truth would devastate her mother, who had health problems and had suffered a heart attack following Stephanie's kidnapping. On the night Stephanie had been released from captivity, her mother had begged her to say that the kidnapper hadn't touched her, and Stephanie decided not to raise the issue. In the months and years that followed, the only person she told about the rape was her friend, Stacy. While Stephanie was in the process of writing her book, it was reported that Michael Samms also intended to write a book, claiming that he and Stephanie were in love and had a consensual
她最初隐瞒这一信息，是因为她害怕真相会打击到她的母亲，其母本就有健康问题，并在斯蒂芬妮被绑架后心脏病发作。在斯蒂芬妮获释当晚，她的母亲曾恳求她说绑架者没有碰过她，于是斯蒂芬妮决定不再提及此事。在随后的几个月和几年里，她唯一倾诉过强奸经历的人就是她的朋友斯黛西。正当斯蒂芬妮着手写书时，有报道称迈克尔·萨姆斯也打算写一本书，声称他和斯蒂芬妮相爱并有一段你情我愿的私情。
affair. Stephanie was incensed by the claims, later stating, quote, It felt as if I was being raped all over again. I was taking antidepressants and drinking heavily to try to stop the flashbacks and nightmares. I was drinking two bottles of wine a night in the hope of sinking into some kind of oblivion. Stephanie's co-writer eventually convinced her not to let Samms bully her, and she persevered with telling the truth in her book. She later said that this decision was, quote, The best thing I ever did, I just wished I'd have done it earlier. When the rape became public knowledge following the book's publication in 1995,
这些言论激怒了斯蒂芬妮，她后来发表声明说：“这感觉就像我又被强奸了一次。我当时在服用抗抑郁药并大量饮酒，试图阻止闪回和噩梦。我一晚喝两瓶酒，希望能借此进入某种遗忘的状态。”斯蒂芬妮的合著者最终说服她不要向萨姆斯的霸凌低头，她坚持在书中说出了真相。她后来表示，这个决定是“我做过的最好的事，我只希望自己能早点这样做”。当1995年该书出版后，强奸一事大白于天下，
Michael Samms threatened to sue Stephanie for libel, but was prevented from doing so by the prison service. On October 24, 1995, probation officer Julia Flack was in her office when Michael Samms entered without warning, armed with a sharpened metal rod he'd stolen from a prison workshop. Julia screamed for help and pressed an alarm button, but Samms threw a lunch tray at her and proceeded to headbutt her. Another prisoner heard the attack and came to Julia's rescue. He managed to overpower Samms before prison officers arrived seconds later. Due to this quick intervention, Julia only required minor medical treatment. Samms was transferred to the prison's segregation unit and charged
迈克尔·萨姆斯威胁要以诽谤罪起诉斯蒂芬妮，但被监狱管理局阻止。1995年10月24日，缓刑监督官朱莉·弗拉克正在办公室里，迈克尔·萨姆斯毫无预兆地闯了进来，手里拿着从监狱车间偷来的削尖的金属棒。朱莉尖叫求救并按下警报按钮，但萨姆斯向她扔了一个午餐盘并开始用头撞她。另一名囚犯听到了袭击声并赶来营救朱莉。他在狱警几秒钟后赶到之前成功制服了萨姆斯。由于这次迅速的干预，朱莉只需接受轻微的医疗处理。萨姆斯被转移到监狱的隔离区，并被控
with false imprisonment and attempted murder. In February 1997, he opted to defend himself a trial. Samms said he had committed the attack because he was angry that the prison service had prevented him from suing Stephanie. He had also wanted to sell some paintings for charity, but these had been confiscated. He claimed to have entered Julia Flack's office to stage a peaceful demonstration and had planned to hold her hostage until police were called, at which point, he intended to take his own life. Jurors found Samms guilty of false imprisonment, but not guilty of attempted murder, and he was sentenced to a further eight years. He is now among the oldest and longest serving
非法拘禁和谋杀未遂。1997年2月，他在审判中选择自己辩护。萨姆斯称他发动袭击是因为愤怒于监狱管理局阻止他起诉斯蒂芬妮。他还想卖掉一些画作做慈善，但这些画作被没收了。他声称进入朱莉·弗拉克的办公室是为了举行和平抗议，并计划将她扣为人质，直到警方被召集，届时他打算自杀。陪审团裁定萨姆斯非法拘禁罪名成立，但谋杀未遂罪名不成立，他被判处额外八年监禁。他现在是英格兰和威尔士服刑时间最长、年龄最大的终身监禁犯之一。
life sentence prisoners in England and Wales. Over the years, Stephanie Slater continued to use her traumatic ordeal to help others. She helped various police departments improve their interactions with kidnapped victims and provided support to other survivors of crime. In 2011, she said, quote, In a 2012 interview with the journalist Keith Wilkinson, Stephanie said, I ran away from my name, Steph, for a long time because of everything it was attached to. But the thing was, I didn't realise when I was running so fast that I've actually come back into contact with her again. This time around, I'm proud of what she's done,
多年来，斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特一直用她痛苦的经历来帮助他人。她协助各个警察局改善与被绑架受害者的互动，并为其他犯罪幸存者提供支持。2011年，她说道，在2012年接受记者基思·威尔金森采访时，斯蒂芬妮说：“由于它所附带的一切，我逃避我的名字‘斯蒂芬’很长时间。但问题是，当我跑得这么快时，我没有意识到我实际上又和她接触了。这一次，我为她所做的一切感到骄傲，
and I'm proud of what she survived, and I've embraced it again. I'm not going to run away from Stephanie Slater anymore because I've found her again, and it's me. So now I take on board what happened to me, I use it, and hopefully help others through it. Stephanie continued living on the Isle of Wight, where she and her best friend Stacey made plans to start a ghost tour business using a restored 1966 camper van. However, in August 2017, Stephanie was diagnosed with liver cancer at the age of 50 and died just 11 days later. Her funeral was held at the Isle of Wight Cramatorium on September 14. Morners travelled in her vintage camper van while her coffin was carried in a second silver camper. Stephanie's friend Stacey Ketner said,
我也为她所经历的生存感到骄傲，我重新拥抱了她。我再也不会逃避斯蒂芬妮·斯莱特了，因为我又找到了她，那就是我自己。所以现在我接受发生在我身上的事，我利用它，并希望以此帮助他人。”斯蒂芬妮继续住在怀特岛，她和挚友斯黛西在那里计划用一辆修复的1966年露营车开展幽灵之旅业务。然而，2017年8月，50岁的斯蒂芬妮被诊断出患有肝癌，仅仅11天后便去世了。她的葬礼于9月14日在怀特岛火葬场举行。哀悼者乘坐她那辆复古露营车，而她的棺材则由第二辆银色露营车运送。斯蒂芬妮的朋友斯黛西·凯特纳说，
We have had a unique and epic friendship for over 25 years and shared so much together, good and bad times. I know that she truly never got over the events that shaped her life so dramatically in January 1992. It's been an honour and a privilege to be Stephanie's best friend. The West Midlands police also paid tribute to Stephanie in a statement that read, to Stephanie's courage and bravery over the years and for the work she did in helping police officers and victims by sharing her experience. Journalist Keith Wilkinson who worked with Stephanie on a documentary in the 1990s said, There's no doubt her efforts helped pave the way for better support for victims. She also helped raise awareness of the possible dangers faced by
我们拥有超过25年独特而史诗般的友谊，共同分享了那么多经历，无论是好是坏。我知道她从未真正从1992年1月彻底改变她生命的事件中走出来。成为斯蒂芬妮最好的朋友是我的荣幸。西米德兰兹警方也在一份声明中向斯蒂芬妮致敬，其中写道：感谢斯蒂芬妮多年来的勇气和勇敢，以及她通过分享经验帮助警察和受害者的工作。曾于20世纪90年代与斯蒂芬妮合作拍摄纪录片的记者基思·威尔金森表示，毫无疑问，她的努力为受害者获得更好的支持铺平了道路。她还帮助提高了人们对以下潜在危险的认识：
estate agents meeting clients alone. For her bravery and campaigning work, many people owe Stephanie a great debt of gratitude. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
房地产经纪人独自会见客户。为了她的勇敢和宣传工作，许多人对斯蒂芬妮感激不尽。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。